हेलो एवरीवन एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू
ऑल आई एम ऑडिबल एंड लाउड एंड क्लियर प्लीज
टेल मी इन द चैट
प्लीज बता
दीजिए ओके थैंक यू एवरीवन थैंक यू थैंक यू
थैंक
थ थोड़ा सा दो मिनट का और वेट करते हैं
एटलीस्ट थोड़े से स्टूडेंट और आने दीजिए
फिर कंटिन्यू करते
हैं तब तक मुझे यह बताइए लास्ट क्लास में
जो कुछ पढ़ाया था आप लोगों को सब कुछ
क्लियर है एवरीवन
बताइए
बताइए तो मैट्स पलेट को सभी यूज कर लोगे
बता
दीजिए सबको सुनाई तो दे रहा है
ना या मैं सब बोल रहा हूं और आप तक आवाज
नहीं पहुंच
रही प्लीज बता दीजिए
किसका प्रैक्टिकल की बात कर रहे हो
तो एक काम की किया करो आप लोग मेरे जो
सवाल होते हैं उनका जवाब दिया करो प्लीज
बताया करो रिप्लाई किया करो कि सो दैट कि
मुझे पता चल जाए कि आप लोग क्लास में
अवेलेबल हो
मैट्स पलट की तो जगत गुरु आप एक काम कर
सकते हो ट्राई हैक मी पर इसके लैब्स
अवेलेबल है आप वहां से कर सकते
हो मेटा पलट के वहां पर अवेलेबल है आप
उसको साइलस को कर सकते हो मैं आपको अगर
बताता हूं यह रहा ट्राई हैक मी गो टू
ट्राई हैक
मी यह रहा यह रहा एंड अगर मैं यहां पर
लर्निंग फेज भी दिखाता हूं आपको
दिस वन यह रहा मेटा पट इंट्रोडक्शन मीटर
प्रेटर एक्सप्लोइटेशन य तीनों लैब कर
लीजिए
आप एक फ्री है इसमें इंट्रोडक्शन वाली और
जो प्रीमियम है दो मीटर प्रेटर और
एक्सप्लोइटेशन वाली तो अगर आप जब तक कोर्स
है तो चाहो तो एक या दो महीने के लिए चाहो
तो आप एक काम कर सकते हो प्रीमियम ले सकते
हो अदर वाइज आप फ्री वाला कर सकते हो
इसमें मेटा पट यह रही यह तीन लैब्स आर
अवेलेबल आप इन तीनों को सॉल्व करके अगर
अच्छी बात इसको सॉल्व करके आप मेरे को
लिंक दिन पर टैग करते हो तो वह मेरे लिए
काफी अच्छा रहेगा और एक गुड न्यूज होगी
मुझे पता चलेगा कि आप लोग कर रहे हो तो यह
प्रैक्टिस के लिए अच्छा है दूसरा क्या कर
सकते हो आप खुद की जो मैंने एक दिन बीच
में क्लास में बताया था ना कि आपको अगर आप
स्टार्टिंग से आ रहे हो डे वन से क्लास
में तो एक दिन मैंने आपको लिंक प्रोवाइड
किया था कि मेटा स्पल टेबल थ नटू और
विंडोज दोनों के लिए आप अपनी मशीन में
कैसे सेटअप कर सकते हो वहां पर सेटअप करके
आप मेटा पलट को वेरी इजली यूज कर सकते हो
वहां पर भी जितने भी अभी तक जो भी कुछ
मैंने करवाया है रिलेटेड टू एक्टिव
एन्यूमरेशन या एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
या मैंने एन्यूमरेशन के बारे में जो कुछ
भी बताया वो आप वहां पर आप प्रैक्टिस कर
सकते हो
ओके तो अभी
भी दे आर ओनली 35 स्टूडेंट्स
दे आर ओनली 31 स्टूडेंट्स अभी बताइए आप
लोगों का यह लेवल है आप बोलते हो कि सर
रेगुलर क्लासेस कीजिए लाइक एक कोर्स चलता
है ना आप ऐसे क्लासेस कीजिए तो दिस इज द
रिजल्ट आप लोगों के सामने रिजल्ट है
ये आप ही बताइए
तो आईसीयू जो आपका ओरिजिनल नाम नहीं है
जिस य नाम जो आपका अवेलेबल है अगर आज आपका
फर्स्ट डे है तो अभी तक ओनली ज्यादा
क्लासेस नहीं हुई है ओनली 10 क्लास हुई
हैं तो आप एक काम कर सकते हो उनको कवर कर
सकते हो डे वन से डे 10 त आसानी से कवर कर
सकते हो आप क्योंकि एक तो पहली बात तो
पूरा कोर्स हिंदी में है दूसरा आपके पास
नोट्स हैं तो आपको बस क्या करना सुनना है
और उसके उसको इंप्लीमेंट करना है बस इतना
ही करना है और वह लोग वह भी आप नहीं कर
पाते फाइन अखिलेश
ओके क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं फिर आज हम
आज का जो मेन टॉपिक हमारे हैं नमरे फेज
में से वह है आपके नेट बायोस और एसएमबी
एन्यूमरेशन सबसे पहले इनका इंट्रोडक्शन
पार्ट मैं आपको करवाऊंगी कि नेट बायस होता
क्या है और एसएमबी होता क्या है
उसके बाद मैं आपको प्रैक्टिकली बताऊंगा कि
इन परे हम एन्यूमरेशन कैसे कर सकते हैं
विद द हेल्प ऑफ डिफरेंट डिफरेंट टूल्स
ओनली एन्यूमरेशन कवर करूंगा एन्यूमरेशन का
मतलब क्या है कि आपने इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
वाला पार्ट कंप्लीट कर लिया जैसे कि आपने
स्कैनिंग कंप्लीट कर लिया आपने कंप्लीट कर
लिया आपका एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग और आपके पास एक
एक अप्रोच है जैसे कि आपके पास एक आईपी
एड्रेस है और आईपी एड में आपको पता है
कौन-कौन सी सर्विसेस रन कर रही है कौन-कौन
से क्या उसका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हो सकता है
सर्विस का वर्जन कौन सा है और जैसे कि
एफटीपी सर्विस है या नेट बायस सर्विस रन
कर रही है या आपकी बोल सकते हैं कि वेब
सर्वर रन कर रहा है या कोई डाटाबेस रन कर
रहा है तो अभी आपके पास इतनी इंफॉर्मेशन
है अब इस इंफॉर्मेशन के आधार पर हम क्या
करेंगे एन्यूमरेशन करेंगे एन्यूमरेशन मतलब
कि पर्टिकुलर सर्विस को लेकर उसके ऊपर
और भी ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करने की
कोशिश करेंगे उसके बारे में और भी ज्यादा
इंफॉर्मेशन निकालने की कोशिश करेंगे जैसे
कि हमें फर्द अटैक करने के लिए या फर्द
वनटी फाइंड आउट करने के लिए उसका एग्जैक्ट
वर्जन या उसकी जो एग्जैक्ट वलने बिलिटी है
जो अवेलेबल है वह सारी चीजें हम क्या कर
सकते हैं फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं विद द
हेल्प ऑफ एन्यूमरेशन तो एन्यूमरेशन सबसे
मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट पार्ट होता है आपकी पूरी
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग जर्नी के दौरान चाहे
आप
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन करो चाहे आप
स्टार्टिंग फेज में हो कल किसी ने
youtube0 पूछा था सर आप लोग आपने यह जिक्र
किया था मेटा पलट के बारे में सर ऑरी
ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल और ऑक्सिड के साथ आपने सर
यह जिक्र किया था कि पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
में इसका ज्यादा रोल है तो सर प्लीज बता
दीजिए क्या मतलब है पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
का
देखिए हैकिंग करते वक्त एथिकल हैकिंग करते
वक्त या पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करते वक्त आप
क्या करते हो एक लाइफ साइकिल एक कुछ
स्टेप्स फॉलो करते हो स्टेप्स क्या होते
हैं सबसे पहले आप टारगेट के बारे में पता
करते हो उसके बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड
आउट करते हो जब आपके पास कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन
होती है उसके बाद आप क्या करते हो उस
इंफॉर्मेशन होने के बाद उसके बास स्कैनिंग
करते हो कि य वो इंफॉर्मेशन सही है या गलत
है जब वो इंफॉर्मेशन की आपके पास एक नरो
डाउन लिस्ट होती है एक लिस्ट होती है तब
उसके ऊपर आप क्या करते हो एन्यूमरेशन
परफॉर्म करते हो एन्यूमरेशन में आपके पास
एग्जैक्ट डिटेल्स होती है कि उसका ये
वर्जन होगा यह सर्विस है ये ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम है ये सारी डिटेल्स होने के बाद
फिर उसके ऊपर आप क्या करते वलन बिलिटी
एनालिसिस कि ये जो पर्टिकुलर सर्विस है यह
जो पर्टिकुलर वर्जन है या जो पर्टिकुलर
बिल्ड नंबर है ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का क्या यह
किसी वल्नरेबल से जो ऑलरेडी एजिस्ट करती
है आपके इंटरनेट के ऊपर आपके डेटाबेस में
एक्सप्लो डेटाबेस में क्या उसके अंदर कोई
ये वल्नरेबल एजिस्ट करती भी है या नहीं है
यह वनबिल है भी या नहीं है अगर उसके अंदर
कोई भी वल्नरेबल है उस पर्टिकुलर सर्विस
के अंदर उस वर्जन के अंदर उसपे हम क्या
करते हैं एक्सप्लोइटेशन करते हैं
एक्सप्लोइटेशन मतलब इनिशियल फुट होल्ड हम
टारगेट के अंदर क्या करते हैं अपना एक्सेस
ग्रांट करने की कोशिश करते हैं वहां से
उसका सेल मतलब सेल एक्सेस लेते हैं कि हम
उसके ऊपर अपनी कमांड रन कर पाए तो ये
हमारा इनिशियल फुट होल्ड होता है कि सबसे
पहला पैर रखते हैं हम उसके नेटवर्क के
अंदर जब आप सक्सेसफुली एक्सप्लोइट कर लेते
हो सक्सेसफुली वहां से आप एक्सेस गेन कर
लेते हो वहां से कोई आपको सेल मिल जाता है
या आरसी के थ्रू का उसकी कमांड प्राउट मिल
जाता है या व्हाट एवर आप कमांड रन कर सकते
हो रिमोट जब वो चीज एक बार हो जाती है
उसके बाद आपका नेक्स्ट स्टेप आता है पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन अभी पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
में कुछ आठ फेजस होते हैं पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोरेशन में सबसे पहले आप वह मैं
आपको बताऊंगा जब हम प्रैक्टिकल्स कर रहे
होंगे ना लैब्स के ऊपर तो पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज में मैं आपको समझाऊं कि
उसमें क्या करना है कि फिर आप फिर से
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोरेशन फेज में एन्यूमरेशन
करते हो कि क्या जो मेरा एक्सप्लोइटेड
मशीन है क्या वह किसी नेटवर्क से कनेक्टेड
है या नहीं है क्या और भी डिवाइसेज वहां
पर अवेलेबल हैं या नहीं है या अगर और
डिवाइसेज वहां पर अवेलेबल हैं तो मैं उनके
बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करूंगा उनके
बारे में पता करूंगा कि क्या वो अभी भी
अलाइव है एक्टिव है या नहीं है अगर वो
एक्टिव है तो उसके ऊपर सर्विस इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट करूंगा कि कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स
ओपन है कौन-कौन सी सर्विसेस उसके ऊपर रन
कर रही हैं क्या उसका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स
है क्या उसका वर्जन है फिर उस पर मैं क्या
वनटी फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करूंगा ओके
देन एक और चीज है कि अब पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन में आप एक चीज और पता करते
हो कि आपको जो एक्सेस मिला है क्या वह
एक्सेस आपका एक प्रिविलेज एक्सेस है या
नॉन प्रिविलेज एक्सेस है मतलब उसके थ्रू
आप कुछ कर भी सकते हो या नहीं कर सकते ठीक
है अगर एक नॉर्मल यूजर का एक्सेस मिला है
तो सबसे पहला आपका क्या है कि लोकल
एन्यूमरेशन करके थोड़ा बहुत एन्यूमरेशन
करके पता लगा के आप क्या करोगे उसको हायर
प्रिविलेज एक्सेस में कन्वर्ट करने की
कोशिश करोगे मतलब रूट लेवल एडमिन लेवल
या उस लेवल के प्रिविलेज आप एक्सेस करने
के वहां पर क्या करते हो आप प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन करते हो चाहे व विंडोज मशीन हो
चाहे वो लिनक्स मशीन हो ओके जब एक बार
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन कर लेते हो फिर फरदर
आप क्या करते हो दूसरी मशीन को एक्सप्लोइट
करते हो तो यह मतलब होता पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन का वहां पर पिटिंग भी होती
है उसके बाद आप अपने ट्रैक भी क्लियर करते
हो और वहां पर एक और काम करते हो पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज में कि आप क्या बोलते
हैं हां कि अगर आपने क्या कि एक्सेस में
मेंटेन करना वो परसिस्टेंट एक्सेस मेंटेन
करना है कि हो सकता है व लिटी पैच भी होगी
उसके बाद भी आप क्या करोगे अपना खुद का
बैक डोर एक दरवाजा रखोगे कि मैं उससे
बारबार सिस्टम के अंदर आ जा सकूं तो ये
सारी चीजें किसका पार्ट है पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन का समझ पा रहे हो कि यह
होता आपका पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन जिसके बारे
में मैंने आपको मोटा मोटा बता दिया तो
सबको समझ में आया एवरीवन कि क्या होता है
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज सबसे डेंजरस होता
है पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज वहां तक आप
पहुंच के उसको सक्सेसफुली एग्जीक्यूट कर
लेते हो तो
चलो तो अभी बात करते हैं हम
ओके ओके तो सभी रिप्लाई कीजिया करें जब भी
मैं पूछता हूं कि आपको समझ में आया या
नहीं आया सभी को क्या करना है रिप्लाई
करना है रिप्लाई में यस या नो या आपको कोई
डाउट है जब मैं पूछता हूं तब सेम टाइम
आपको रिप्लाई करते रहना है इवन जितने भी
48 है 51 है या 60 स्टूडेंट्स है या 30
स्टूडेंट्स है सभी को रिप्लाई करना है इट
इज ए मैंडेटरी
ओके चलो अभी बात करते हैं हम नेट बायोस के
बारे में थोड़ा सा ओवरव्यू लेते हैं नेट
बायोस होता क्या है
देखो एवरी विंडोज कंप्यूटर हैज ए कंप्यूटर
नेम इवन इफ यू डिड नॉट सेट इट देन द नेम
जनरेट ड्यूरिंग द इंस्टॉलेशन ऑफ द
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इज रिटन देयर हर एक
कंप्यूटर का अपना एक नेम होता है अगर आप
उसको सेट भी नहीं करते हो तब भी जब आप
किसी भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को क्या करते हो
इंस्टॉल करते हो इंस्टॉल करते वक्त वहां
पर जो भी नेम जनरेट होता है वो ऑटोमेटिक
आपके उस कंप्यूटर नेम में स्टोर हो जाता
है उसको आप चाहे तो रिनेम भी कर सकते हो
उसको आप बदल भी सकते हो
ओके सबने देखा होगा जब आप कंप्यूटर की
प्रॉपर्टीज में जाते हो अबाउट द सर्च
करोगे और सेटिंग के अंदर जाओगे अबाउट द
कंप्यूटर पीसी तो वहां पर आपको आपके पीसी
का नाम मिलेगा तो उसी की बात कर रहा हूं
मैं हर एक कंप्यूटर का एक नेम होता है दिस
कंप्यूटर नेम ऑन द लोकल नेटवर्क कैन बी
यूज्ड एज अ कंप्लीट अल्टरनेटिव टू द लोकल
आईपी एड्रेस ओके कि जो कंप्यूटर नेम होता
है लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क के अंदर क्या कर
सकता है उसका जो आईपी एड्रेस होता है उसका
कंप्लीट अल्टरनेटिव के रूप में यूज कर
सकते हैं ओके कि किसको क्या करने के लिए
टू एक्सेस शेयर्स जो नेटवर्क फोल्डर्स हैं
या प्रिंटर्स होते हैं उनको एक्सेस करने
के लिए टू एक्सेस रनिंग वेब सर्विसेस वेब
सर्वर्स एफटीपी एटस बेसिकली क्या होता है
कि लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क के अंदर आप विदाउट
आईपी एड्रेस कंप्यूटर के नेम से भी क्या
कर सकते हो शेयर्स प्रिंटर्स इवन वेब
सर्वर्स या एफटीपी सर्विसेस को क्या कर
सकते हो एक्सेस कर सकते हो ओके इट डज नॉट
रिक्वायर एनी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन ऑफ़ डीएनएस और
होस्ट फाइल्स कि अब इसके लिए आपको ना तो
किसी डीएनए सर्वर की जरूरत है और ना ही
किसी होस्ट फाइल की जरूरत है होस्ट फाइल
क्या होती है
ने देखा होस्ट फाइल के अंदर आप क्या करते
हो मैपिंग करते हो आईपी एड्रेस की डीएनएस
के साथ डोमेन नेम के साथ सिंस सच नेम
रिकॉग्नाइज रिकॉग्निशन इज प्रोवाइडेड बाय
द नेट बॉय और यह सारी चीजें क्या है नेट
बॉय के द्वारा रिकॉग्नाइज की जाती है
प्रोवाइड की जाती है नेट बायस इज
इंपोर्टेंट फॉर विंडोज एज वेल एज फॉर डिगि
इन विंडोज आर्किटेक्चर जो नेट बायस होता
है वो विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के लिए बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है
ओके एनालाइजिंग नेटवर्क एक्टिविटी ऑफ
विंडोज एंड द सिक्योरिटी इ ऑफ द लोकल
नेटवर्क एंड विंडोज कंप्यूटर ओके नाउ
नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पर चलते हैं अभी बात करते
हैं इंट्रोडक्शन टू नेट बायस ये नेट बायस
होता क्या है देखो नेट बायस होता है
नेटवर्क बेसिक इनपुट आउटपुट सिस्टम एक
नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल है या कह सकते हैं एक
एपीआई है एप्लीकेशन प्रोग्रामिंग इंटरफेस
है जो आईबीएम के द्वारा डेवलप किया गया था
अर्ली 080 में ओके इट प्रोवाइड्स ए सेट ऑफ
सर्विस फॉर कम्युनिकेशन बिटवीन कंप्यूटर्स
ऑन ए लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क ओके बेसिकली क्या
करता है कि जो लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क के अंदर
जितने भी पीसीज होते हैं जितने भी
कंप्यूटर्स हैं उनके बीच में कम्युनिकेशन
करने के लिए कुछ सर्विसेस प्रोवाइड करता
है सेट ऑफ सर्विसेस प्रोवाइड करता है किसी
कुछ पोर्ट्स के ऊपर नेट बॉय अलाउ
एप्लीकेशन टू कम्युनिकेट ओवर ए नेटवर्क
एंड प्रोवाइड्स ए नेमिन सिस्टम टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
वाइस की हेल्प से एक डिवाइस से दूसरे
डिवाइस को क्या कर सकते हो
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
डिजाइन टू ऑपरेट ओवर आईबीएम पीसी नेटवर्क
ओरिजनली तो यह क्या
हैट वेट ए मिनट गाइस
ओके नली डिजाइन टू ऑपरेट ववर आईबीएम पीसी
नेटवर्क एंडले अडॉप्टेड बाय माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
फॉर विंडोज बेसिकली क्या है कि आईबीएम ने
अपने अपने नेटवर्क के लिए डेवलप किया था
इसको नेट बॉयस को लेकिन बाद में जो
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट है उसने विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के लिए अडॉप्ट कर लिया नेट बॉयस
हैज ए हैज बिकम ए की प्रोटोकॉल इन मेनी
नेटवर्किंग एनवायरमेंट और उस टाइम पर जो
नेट बॉय था एक की प्रोटोकॉल बन गया था
आपके नेटवर्किंग एनवायरमेंट के अंदर ओके
वाइल इट हैज बीन लार्जली सुपरसीडेड बाय
न्यू टेक्नोलॉजी सच एज डीएनएस एंड एसएमबी
इन मॉडर्न नेटवर्क हालांकि जो मॉडर्न
नेटवर्क है उन्होंने क्या कर दिया नेट
बायस को का जो यूसेज है कम कर दिया है
कौन-कौन सी जो नई टेक्नोलॉजी है डीएनएस है
डोमेन नेम सिस्टम है या एसएमबी है सर्वर
मैसेज ब्लॉक है इ इट रिमेंस रेलीवेंट इन
सम लीगेसी और स्मॉलर नेटवर्क्स लेकिन जो
छोटे-छोटे नेटवर्क्स हैं अभी भी उनमें यूज
किया जा रहा है ओके अभी नेट बायस कैसे काम
करता है उसके बारे में जानते हैं नेट बायस
ऑपरेट्स प्राइमर एट द सेशन लेयर लेयर फाइव
ऑफ द ओ एसआई मॉडल ओआई मॉडल की सेशन लेयर
पे ऑपरेट करता है एंड प्रोवाइड द फॉलोइंग
की सर्विसेस सबसे पहले जो सर्विस प्रोवाइड
करता है नेम रेजुलस
मतलब आईपी टू नेम में कन्वर्ट करता है तो
नेट बायस अलाउ मशीन टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन नेम हो सकता है आप जो क्या
होता है आपका ह्यूमन डेवल्स में होता है
ठीक है तो नेट बॉय क्या नेट बॉय की हेल्प
से क्या कर सकते हो कि वो ह्यूमन डेवल्स
के थ्रू आप क्या है अपने डिवाइसेटी फाई कर
सकते हो नेटवर्क के अंदर डिवाइस को
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
नेम में इसी प्रकार से यह भी क्या करता है
आपके आईपी है उनको क्या लोकल एरिया
नेटवर्क में जो आईपी एड्रेसस होते हैं
उनको क्या जोल करता है नेट वायस आपके जो
मशीन के नेम के अंदर नेम रेजोल रेजोल्यूशन
कैन बी अचीव्ड इन थ्री वेज जो नेम रेजोल
है रेजोल्यूशन है वो तीन तरीकों से अचीव
किया जा सकता है एक तो ब्रॉडकास्ट करके
दूसरा विन विंडोज इंटरनेट नेम सर्विस के
द्वारा तीसरा एलम होस्ट फाइल के द्वारा
ब्रॉडकास्ट मतलब क्या करता है द
रिक्वेस्टिंग कंप्यूटर सेंड्स ए
ब्रॉडकास्ट मैसेज टू द लोकल नेटवर्क
आस्किंग फॉर द आईपी एड्रेस
करेस्पॉन्डिंग्ली
क्या करता है कि जो लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क के
अंदर कोई भी एक पीसी क्या करता है जितने
भी पीसी है सभी को क्या करता है
ब्रॉडकास्ट कर देता है कि ओके यह आईपी
एड्रेस है इस आईपी एड्रेस के अगेंस्ट मुझे
पीसी का नेट बायस नेम बता दीजिए दूसरी
क्या है कि अगर आपका लार्ज एरिया नेटवर्क
है मतलब बहुत बड़ा नेटवर्क है उस केस में
क्या करते हैं विन सर्वर का यूज किया जाता
है लाइक डीएनएस विन सर्वर का यूज किया
जाता है जो इस काम को क्या करता है आईपी
टू नेट वायस नेम में रिजॉल्व करता है जो
अपने अंदर स्टोर करके रखता है ओके तीसरी
जो एलम होस्ट फाइल है एक स्टेटिक फाइल
होती है जट यूज टू मैप नेट वायस नेम टू
आईपी एड्रेस मैनुअली ओके एक छोटी सी फाइल
होता है बिल्कुल ही छोटा नेटवर्क है तो उस
केस में क्या एक स्टेटिक फाइल ऐड कर दी
जाती है जिसमें क्या है जो सिस्टम है
ऑटोमेटिक अपनी इस फाइल के अंदर चेक कर
सकता है ओके इस आईपी एड्रेस के अगेंस्ट ये
नेट वायस नेम है तो इन तरीके से क्या है
इन तरीकों से क्या किया जा सकता है नेम
रेजोल किया जा सकता है नेट बायोस के अंदर
अभी दूसरा कम्युनिकेशन जो सर्विस है नेट
बायोस प्रोवाइड्स बोथ कनेक्शन लेस
कम्युनिकेशन वाया डेटा ग्राम्स एंड
कनेक्शन ओरिएंटेड कम्युनिकेशन वाय सेशंस
बेसिकली क्या कर सकते हो कि नेट वायर्स के
थ्रू आप क्या कर सकते हो दो टाइप के
कम्युनिकेशन कर सकते हो एक तो कनेक्शन लेस
यूडीपी पोर्ट के द्वारा और एक कनेक्शन
ओरिएंटेड टीसीपी पोर्ट के द्वारा क्या कर
सकते हो सेशन एस्टेब्लिश करके कम्युनिकेशन
कर सकते हो वही चीज इसमें बताई गई है डेटा
ग्राम सर्विस यूडीपी दिस प्रोवाइड्स
कनेक्शन लेस कम्युनिकेशन मीनिंग मैसेज आर
सेंट विदाउट एस्टेब्लिशिंग ए डायरेक्ट
कनेक्शन बिटवीन डिवाइसेज इट ऑफेंस यूज्ड
फॉर ब्रॉडकास्ट एंड क्विक और वन टू मेनी
मैसेज बेसिकली ब्रॉडकास्ट के लिए ज्यादातर
यूज़ किया जाता है कौन से डटा ग्राम
सर्विस को सेशन सर्विस क्या है दिस
प्रोवाइड रिलायबल कनेक्शन ओरिएंटेड
कम्युनिकेशन मीनिंग ए सेशन इज एस्टेब्लिश
बिटवीन डिवाइस टू इंश्योर दैट डाटा इज
ट्रांसफर्ड करेक्टली इन ऑर्डर दिस इज
यूज्ड फॉर मोर सिक्योर एंड रिलायबल डाटा
ट्रांसफर लाइक फाइल शेयरिंग करनी है या
प्रिंटिंग करनी है उस केस में आप क्या कर
सकते हो टीसीपी जो प्रोटोकॉल्स है जो
टीसीपी सेशन सर्विस है जो इसका इसके
अगेंस्ट एक पोर्ट है उसको यूज कर सकते हो
आप कम्युनिकेशन के लिए अभी ये तीन पोर्ट्स
यूज किए जाते हैं आपके नेट बॉयस के केस
में पोर्ट 137 यूडीपी पोर्ट्स यूज्ड फॉर
नेट बायस नेम सर्विस रेजल एनबीएनएस नेट
बायस नेम सर्विस रेजोल्यूशन के काम कर ये
क्या करता है आपका नेट बायस नेम को आईपी
एड्रेस में रिजॉल्व करता है पोर्ट नंबर
138 जनरली आपने विंडोज मशीन के ऊपर अभी
रिसेंटली जितनी भी हमने लैब्स की थी उसके
अंदर आपने देखा होगा यूज्ड फॉर नेट वॉइस
डाटा ग्राम सर्विस व्हिच प्रोवाइड्स
कनेक्शन लेस कम्युनिकेशन बेसिकली नेम
क्यूरीज या ब्रॉडकास्ट आपको करना तो हम
क्या करते हैं पोर्ट 138 का यूज करते हैं
पोर्ट 139 जो टीसीपी पोर्ट है यूज्ड फॉर
नेट वॉय सेशन सर्विस एनबीएसएस जिसको हम
बोलते हैं अगर आप वाय आर्क में देखोगे
व्हिच प्रोवाइड्स कनेक्शन ओरिएंटेड
कम्युनिकेशन फॉर सर्विसेस लाइक फाइल
शेयरिंग एंड फेंडिंग सबसे पहले क्या होता
है ये तीनों चीज सीक्वेंस में काम करती है
सबसे पहले क्या होता है 137 पोर्ट के थ्रू
नेम रेजुलस किया जाता है उसके बाद क्या
किया जाता है अगर हमें ब्रॉडकास्ट करना
उसके बाद चूज किया जाता है मुझे 138 को
यूज करना है या 139 को यूज करना है अपने
कम्युनिकेशन के लिए ओके नाउ उसके बाद जो
फोर्थ है नेमिन सिस्टम ईच मशीन और सर्विस
इन ए नेट बॉयस नेटवर्क इज आइडेंटिफिकेशन
होती है जो सर्विस है नेट वॉइस नेटवर्क के
अंदर अगर नेट वॉइस नेटवर्क को आप यूज कर
रहे हो लोकल या नेटवर्क में वो किसके
द्वारा
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
यूज टू रिप्रेजेंट द सर्विस टाइप कि फाइल
शेयरिंग या प्रिंटिंग मतलब 16 कैरेक्टर
लॉन्ग होता है लेकिन जो 15 कक्ट व वैलिड
होते हैं इसका नेम होता नेट ब ने 16 कक्टर
हो सकता है व आपकी टाइप्स ऑफ सर्विस
डिफाइन करता है नेट वॉइस के अंदर ना उसके
बाद हम बात करते हैं नेट बॉय सर्विसेस के
बारे में कि नेट बय तीन टाइप की सर्विसेस
आपको प्रोवाइड करता मैंने आपको बताया था
नेट बस नेम सर्विस एनबी एनएस नेट बस डटा
ग्राम सर्विस आपको एनबी एसएस
और
य नेट बायोस
च टाइप ऑफ सर्विस वेर इज द ये रहा
एनबीडीएस और एक एनबीएसएस जिसको हम बोलते
हैं कौन सा नेटवर्क सेशन सर्विस अब तीनों
सर्विस क्या काम करती है आपको पता चल गया
एक तो नेम रेजुलस का काम करती है दूसरी
कनेक्शन लेस कम्युनिकेशन एस्टेब्लिश करने
के लिए अब ये देखो यहां पर रिस्पांस अ नेट
वायस नेम सर्विस क्या करती है रिस्पांसिबल
फॉर द रजिस्ट्रेशन एंड रेजोल्यूशन ऑफ नेट
वॉयस नेम्स दिस अलाउ डिवाइसेटी फाई ईच अदर
यूजिंग नेम इंस्टेड ऑफ़ आईपी एड्रेस विन
सर्वर आर यूज्ड इन लार्ज नेटवर्क टू मैनेज
नेम रेजोल्यूशन सेंट्रली या रदर देन
रिलाइंग ऑन द ब्रॉडकास्टिंग मैंने आपको
बताया था विन सर्वर यह डीएनएस की तरह काम
करता है नेटबस नेम रेजोल्यूशन के लिए अब
नेटबस डटा ग्राम सर्विस क्या करती है इट
प्रोवाइड्स कनेक्शन लेस कम्युनिकेशन फॉर
सेंडिंग शॉर्ट मैसेजेस ओवर द नेटवर्क इट
टिपिकली वर्क्स वाय यूडीपी पोर्ट 138 और
जो नेट बस नेम सर्विस है वह आपकी यूडीपी
पोर्ट 130 से 7 अलांग फॉर वन टू मेनी
कम्युनिकेशंस ब्रॉडकास्टिंग लेकिन
ज्यादातर यूडीपी पोर्ट 138 ही यूज किया
जाता है रेयरली होता है कि टीसीपी पोर्ट
138 यूज किया जा रहा हो नेटवर्क सेशन
सर्विस प्रोवाइड्स कनेक्शन ओरिएंटेड
कम्युनिकेशन वाय टीसीपी पोर्ट 139 दिस
इंश्योर दैट डाटा इज डिलीवर्ड रिलायबली
एंड इन ऑर्डर दिस इज यूज्ड फॉर एक्टिविटी
सच एज फाइल एंड प्रिंटिंग सेरिंग तीनों
चीज वही है लेकिन मैं आपको अभी फिर से
बताया है कि नेट बस का काम ये तीन सर्विस
प्रोवाइड करने का है
एवरीवन गट क्लियर अभी तक सबको समझ में आया
कि नेट बॉयस होता क्या है नेट बॉयस कैसे
काम करता है उसके क्या-क्या फीचर्स है कौन
सी तीन सर्विसेस को प्रोवाइड करता है
इन्हीं का हम फायदा उठाएंगे अपने
न्यूमरेशन फेज में एवरीवन गट
क्लियर सभी से आंसर चाहिए मुझे
किसी कोई डाउट
है क्विक रकप यह है कि देखिए यह रहा नेट
बायस क्या होता है नेट बायस एक नेटवर्क बस
इनपुट आउटपुट सिस्टम है मतलब एक ऐसा
प्रोटोकॉल है जो क्या करता है आपके जो
सिस्टम्स है जो आपकी विंडोज मशीन है उसमें
क्या करता है नेमिन कन्वेंशन क्या करता है
नेम रिजॉल्व करता है जैसे कि आप क्या
डीएनएस कैसे काम करता है डीएन आपके डोमेन
रिजॉल्व करता है ना आईपी को डोमेन में उसी
तरीके से नेट बॉयस क्या करता है आपके जो
मशीन है जो कंप्यूटर का नेम होता है ना
उसको रिजॉल्व करता है उसको नेट बॉयस नेम
टू मशीन नेम टू आईपी या आईपी टू मशीन नेम
में बेसिकली जो लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क होता
है या वन बोल सकते हो वाइड एरिया नेटवर्क
इसके अंदर आप नेट वायस का यूज कर सकते हो
किसके लिए अपनी फाइल शेयर करने के लिए या
प्रिंटर शेयर करने के लिए ओके इन सब परपज
से हम पहले नेट वायस का यूज करते थे उसके
बाद य तीन सर्विसेस करता है एक तो नेम
रेजुलस दूसरा उसके बाद कनेक्शन लेस
कनेक्शन पोर्ट नंबर 138 प ये क्या करता है
डटा ग्राम सर्विस का यूज करता है कनेक्शन
लेस यूडीपी पोर्ट और टीसीपी पोर्ट ये क्या
है एक सेशन सर्विस मतलब एक सेशन
एस्टेब्लिश करता है उसके बाद फाइल शेयरिंग
या प्रिंटिंग वाले काम करता है एवरीवन अभी
यह क्विक रिकप था आपको शायद समझ में आ गया
होगा ये पूरे नेट बय का रोल ही यही है कि
नेट बॉ नेम सर्विस नेटबस डटा ग्राम सर्विस
नेटबस सेशन सर्विस पहले सबसे पहले क्या
करता है नेम रेजुलस करता है देन उसके बाद
क्या करता है इनमें से या तो पोर्ट 138 का
यूज करेगा अपनी इंफॉर्मेशन शेयर करने के
लिए मैसेज शेयर करने के लिए या क्या करेगा
से सेशन सर्विस का यूज करेगा अपनी
इंफॉर्मेशन डिलीवरी करने के लिए या कि कोई
प्रिंट करना है या कोई फाइल शेयर करनी है
आपने पता है ना कि शेयर फोल्डर अबब आजकल
एसएमबी का यूज किया जाता है शेयर फोल्डर
में लेकिन पहले नेट वायस का यूज किया जाता
था आप शेयर फोल्डर क्या कर सकते थे कि आप
अपने मशीन का नाम या आईपी एड्रेस डालते थे
उसके बाद डबल फॉरवर्ड बैकवर्ड स्लश देन
उसके बाद आप उस शेयर को एक्सेस करते थे तो
वो किसके थ्रू पॉसिबल था वो पॉसिबल था
आपके नेट बायोस के थ्रू शायद सबको याद आ
गया
होगा बताऊंगा मैं
अभी सबको समझ में आ
गया
चलो अभी थोड़ा सा और इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड
करता हूं आपको नेट बस इन मॉडर्न
नेटवर्किंग लद नेटबस वास ओरिजनली यूज इन
स्मॉल एंड लोकल नेटवर्क इट्स यूसेज इन
मॉडर्न इंटरप्राइज नेटवर्क हैज डिक्रीज
ड्यू टू द इंट्रोडक्शन ऑफ मोर रोब
प्रोटोकॉल लाइक एबी फॉर फाइल शेयरिंग एंड
डीएनएस फॉर नेम रेगुलेशन पहले क्या होता
जब डीएनएस नहीं था तो नेम रेगुलेशन पर्पस
के लिए भी हम नेट बायस का ही यूज करते थे
लेकिन अभी क्या है कि इसका यूज कम हो गया
है किसकी किसकी वजह से एसएमबी आ गया और
डीएनएस आ गया डीएनएस डीएनएस अपना काम करता
है नेम रेजोल्यूशन वाला और एसएमबी क्या
करता है अभी आजकल फाइल शेयरिंग का काम
करता है नेट स्टिल प्ले ए रोल इन लीगेसी
सिस्टम पर्टिकुलर इन ओल्डर वर्जन
एनवायरमेंट ओल्डर विज नमेंट एंड इन सर्टेन
सिनेरियो वेर एसएमबी और नेट बायस इज
रिक्वायर्ड अभी क्या है कि जो कुछ ओल्डर
विंडोज अभी भी यूज होती है विंड 7 या
पुरानी विंडोज खासकर जहां पर इंडस्ट्री
में क्योंकि उनके बेस पर सॉफ्टवेयर
डिफाइंड है उन्हीं के बेस पर वो मशीने काम
करती हैं और नए वाले जो विंडोज 8 है इन पर
वो मतलब क्या कह सकते कंफर्टेबल नहीं है
तो वहां पर क्या है नेट वायस का आज भी यूज
किया जाता है या एसएमबी अगर क्या कर रहा
है अभी कुछ एसम वर्जंस पुराने वाले वर्जंस
हैं जो क्या करते हैं नेट बायस का यूज
करते हैं क्या करने के लिए फाइल शेयरिंग
और प्रिंटिंग के लिए पोर्ट नंबर 139 या
पोर्ट नंबर 137 नेट बायस सर्विस उससे पहले
क्या होगा एसएमबी यूज करने से पहले नेट
बायस की सारी सर्विसेस ऑन होंगी देन आप
क्या कर सकते हो एसएमबी यूज कर सकते हो तो
इसलिए बोला गया कि आज भी क्या एसएमबी और
नेट वायस यूज किया जाता है तो वहां पर
क्या नेट वायस की जरूरत है फॉर एग्जांपल
विंडोज फाइल एंड प्रिंटिंग शेयरिंग सर्विस
व हिस्टोरिक बेस्ड ऑन नेट बायोस मेनी
मॉडर्न विंडोज मशीन स्टिल स्पोर्ट नेट
बायोस बट प्रोटोकॉल इज ऑफर डिसेबल्ड और
रिप्लेस बाय एसएमबी ओवर टीसीपी आईपी
विदाउट यूजिंग नेट वायस हालांकि क्या है
कि आजकल आजकल क्या है कि डिसेबल आपका नेट
वॉय बाय डिफॉल्ट आपके मशीन के अंदर अगर
नहीं भी है तो आपको डिसेबल रखना चाहिए
क्योंकि या आप या आपका जो यह है क्या
एसएमबी है एसएमबी आजकल जो लेटेस्ट वर्जन
थ्री है का जो 3.0 है या 3.1 है वह क्या
कर रहे हैं नेट वायस का यूज नहीं कर रहे
वो क्या कर रहे डायरेक्टली टीसीपी आईपी
प्रोटोकॉल का ही यूज कर रहे हैं अपनी
सर्विस को यूज करने के लिए वहां पर नेट
वायस की जरूरत नहीं है डायरेक्टली टीसीपी
आईपी प्रोटोकॉल का यूज करेगा एमबी और अपनी
फाइल शेयरिंग और प्रिंटिंग प्रिंटर
शेयरिंग वाले काम कर लेगा लेकिन फिर भी
स्टिल जो वर्जन 2.0 है कुछ पहले वाले
वर्जंस है जो स्टिल आज भी यूज करते हैं
नेट वायस का तो यह था नेट वायस की कहानी
क्योंकि आजकल नेट वायस
किसी में देखने को मिलता है किसी में
देखने को नहीं मिलता लेकिन ज्यादातर ज
जितनी भी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग आप मशीन
परफॉर्म करोगे चाहे आप एग्जाम में कोई भी
मशीन यूज करो या वहां पर आपको नेटवर्क्स
देखने को मिलेगा विंडोज प भी और किसके
अंदर लिनक्स के भी अंदर ओके लिनक्स में
किस पर्पस से यूज करते हैं वो भी मैं आपको
बताऊंगा लिनक्स में यूज होता
है नहीं अखिलेश अगर लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क है
लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क में आपको डिवाइस को
कम्युनिकेट करने के लिए मैक एड्रेस भी
चाहिए और आईपी एड्रेस भी चाहिए तो लोकल
नेटवर्क में अगर आप डीएनएस सर्वर भी क्या
बोल सकते हो डीएसीपी सर्वर या तो ऑटोमेटिक
कन्फर नहीं तो आप स्टेटिक आईपी भी रखते हो
ओके विदाउट आईपी तो आपका डिवाइस
कम्युनिकेट करेगा नहीं आपके प्राइवेट
नेटवर्क में लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क क्या है
आपका खुद का प्राइवेट नेटवर्क है समझ रहे
हो एक कंपनी का खुद का प्राइवेट नेटवर्क
जो एक्सटर्नली एक्सेसिबल नहीं है उसके
अंदर यह काम करता
है बिल्कुल बल एटली काम करता है
ये अभी आप लोगों का टास्क नंबर वन यहां पर
क्या है मैं आपको बता देता हूं आपका टास्क
नंबर वन यहां पर यह है कि आप लोगों को यह
पता करना कि सर नेट बायस की एक्चुअल
वर्किंग प्रिंसिपल कैसे किय कैसे रिजॉल्व
करता है जैसे कि आपने पता है ना टीसीपी
थवे हैंड शेक होता है ऐसे या एसएमबी
एक्चुअल में कैसे हैंड शेक करता है या
कैसे फाइल शेयरिंग करता है बिहाइंड दी
थ्योरी तो यह चीज आप लोगों का टास्क है
नेट एसएमबी के केस में उसकी वर्किंग
डिटेल्स वर्किंग अगर आपको चाहे वो पीके
फाइल एनालाइज करके मिल रही हो जैसे कि
वायसर के थ्रू या आप कोई आर्टिकल आपको ऐसा
मिलता है यह आपको क्या करना है रिसर्च
करना है और रिसर्च करके आपको क्या करना है
लिंक दिन पे पोस्ट डालनी है और इसमें
डिफरेंस अकेडमी प्लस में मेरे को आप आप
लोग मैक्सिमम लोग मेरे क्या है ग्रुप में
हो मैक्सिमम लोगों ने मेरे को रिक्वेस्ट
भेजा तो मेरे को टैग करोगे ये आप लोगों का
टास्क है कि नेट बायस की वर्किंग
प्रिंसिपल की कैसे यह शेयर करता है कैसे
मतलब कि नेम रेजोल्यूशन कैसे करता है कैसे
कनेक्शन लेस या कनेक्शन ओरिएंटेड कनेक्शन
में एब्लिश करता है और आप कैसे उसको
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
एक होता है ना उसी प्रकार के ये दोनों
टास्क आपके हैं ये दो के दो टास्क लिख
लेना और ये दोनों टास्क आपको क्या करने
हैं डिटेल रिसर्च चाहे आपको इसके लिए दो
दिन लगे तीन दिन लगे एक दिन लगे आपके इसके
ऊपर आपको क्या करना है इसके ऊपर डिटेल
रिसर्च करनी है बढ़िया से आर्टिकल्स लिखने
हैं बढ़िया से आर्टिकल्स को आपको क्या
करना है पोस्ट करना है लिंक दिन पर जिसमें
आप मेरे को और डिफरेंस अकेडमी दोनों को
टैग करोगे हो जाएगा
एवरीवन हो जाएगा
बताइए सभी के सभी आंसर दीजिए
मुझे दे टोटल 46 जिनमें से 40 तो आंसर
एटलीस्ट आने चाहिए
100% ट्राई करना है क्योंकि आपको अगर ग
करोगे प्लस में ो और प्लस में चैट जीपीटी
करोगे आप इसके ऊपर मैं बता रहा हूं 10 15
पेज के आर्टिकल्स लिख दोगे आप फाइंड आउट
करके एक बार ट्राई तो करना आपको बिल्कुल
इजी लैंग्वेज में मिल जाएगा सच में
अवेलेबल है मैं झूठ नहीं बोल रहा सच में
अवेलेबल
है ओके नाउ अभी मैं आपको फिर भी दिखा देता
हूं
देखो जब नेम रेजोल किया जाता है नेट बायस
के थ्रू अ एन एनबी एनएस आपको क्या करना है
जब भी आप ब्रॉडकास्ट मैसेज करेगा जैसे फॉर
एग्जांपल यह रहा
192.168 z101 ने क्या किया ब्रॉडकास्ट
किया एनबी एनएस किया प्रोटोकॉल का यूज़
किया मैंने क्या बताया था नेम रेजोल्यूशन
तो क्या करता है यह क्यूरी करता है इसने
ब्रॉडकास्ट कर दिया क ओके हैकर वेयर ट
सर्वर यह नेट बायस नेम है तो प्लीज मुझे
इसके अगेंस्ट किसका आईपी एड्रेस है मतलब
ये नाम किसका है तो आप मुझे क्या करना है
इसके अगेंस्ट आईपी एड्रेस प्रोवाइड किए
इसने ब्रॉडकास्ट किए देखिए नेट
बायस नेम सर्विस यहां पर देखोगे फ्लैक्स
ये टर नेम ये है उसके बाद क्या है यह इसका
ब्रॉडकास्ट मैसेज है यह इसका ब्रॉडकास्ट
मैसेज है फर्स्ट वाला देखिए यहां पर दिख
रहा सबको सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा है
अब इसका रिस्पांस मिलता है इसके रिस्पांस
में जो आपका अभी जो ब्रॉडकास्ट किया था तो
जिसका जो नेट बायोस नेम था हैक वेयर सर्वर
तो
वह 53 था
192.168 53 वो बताता ओके यह मेरा नाम है
हैकवे सर्वर और यह मेरा आईपी एड्रेस उसने
रिस्पांस किया देखिए नेटवर्क नेम सर्विस
इसका आंसर है देखो र शेयर टाइप एनबी क्लास
आयन हैकवे शेयर एंड देखो ये इसका आईपी
एड्रेस है 192.168 053 इस तरीके से क्या
है आपका ब्रॉडकास्ट क्यूरी की जाती है और
उसका मैसेज रिसीव किया जाता है नेक्स्ट
उसके बाद अभी क्या है ए रिक्वेस्ट टू
स्पेसिफिक होस्ट टू ऑब्टेन इट्स होस्ट नेम
टू ऑब्टेन इट्स होस्ट नेम देखिए ए
रिक्वेस्ट टू होस्ट ऑप्शन इ होम दे
स्पेसिफिक जैसे कि
192.168 0.101 ने डायरेक्टली किसको
रिक्वेस्ट किया नेम सर्विस
192.168 53 को रिक्वेस्ट की कि प्लीज आप
मेरे को होस्ट नेम बताइए होस्ट ने होस्ट
नेम मतलब आप मेरे को नेट बायोस नेम बताइए
अपना होस्ट नेम बताइए ओके नेट बायोस नेम
बता दीजिए या मुझे अपना होस्ट नेम बता
दीजिए आप डायरेक्टली ये भी कर सकते हो
उल्टा आईपी टू होस्ट नेम तो अब इसका
रिस्पांस आता है उसके रिस्पांस में आप
क्या देखोगे देखो इसका भी रिस्पांस रिसीव
करता है य यहां पर ज़ूम करोगे तो यहां पर
आपको दिखाई दे रहा होगा रिस्पांस में ये
रहा इसका होस्ट नेम ये क्या कर रहा मेरा
इसका था आंसर में आता उसको हैक वेयर सर्वर
अभी इसने आंसर में क्या किया उसने
डायरेक्ट आईपी को रिक्वेस्ट भेजी तो ये
अपने रिस्पांस में क्या कर रहा हैकवे
सर्वर और बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
प्रोवाइड कर रहा है तो ये बेसिक मैं आपको
दिखा रहा हूं कि कुछ प्री कैप्चर
स्क्रीनशॉट्स हैं जो अवेलेबल थे आपके
google3 लिखा है तो अच्छा काम किया है तो
मैं आपको सिर्फ डायरेक्टली शो कर रहा हूं
नेक्स्ट यह आपका क्या है कनेक्शन कनेक्शन
ओरिएंटेड कनेक्शन ओरिएंटेड आपका
स्क्रीनशॉट है देखिए यहां पर देखिए सोर्स
ये आईपीवी सिक्स डेस्टिनेशन एन बीएसएस
सेशन एस्टेब्लिश किया टीसीपी ये देखो इस
तरीके से सेशन स्टब लिश किया तो इस तरीके
से आपका एक्चुअल में काम करता है बिहाइंड
द नेट बॉय मैं आपको एक रफ आईडिया दे दिया
मोटा-मोटा आइडिया आपको मैंने बता दिया अब
ये आपका काम है इस पे डिटेल रिसर्च करना
ओके वरना देखो उस कोर्स को फिर फिनिश भी
करना ना भाई तो ओबवियसली यह आपको थोड़ा सा
इनोवेटिव थोड़ा सा रिसर्च ये दोनों काम
आपको खुद से करने होंगे ओके हो जाएगा सबसे
यह मैंने आपको डीप एक्सप्लेन कर
दिया नहीं ब्लर नहीं होगा यार आप उसकी
क्वालिटी सेलेक्ट कीजिए अगर आपके पास
अच्छा इंटरनेट है
1080 या उसको व कीजिए तो यह थोड़ा सा यह
वाली स्लीट हो सकती है ब्लर हो सकती है
लेकिन आपको जब मिलेगी तो आप इसको कर सकते
हो
नेक्स्ट मैं आपको बताता हूं अभी एसएमबी
एन्यूमरेशन तो नेट बायस में किसी का कोई
डाउट है नेट बायस में किसी का कोई डाउट है
किसी को लगता सर मेरा डाउट रह
गया क्योंकि नेट बॉस ऐसे कोई नहीं
बताएगा
बताइए नेट बायस में किसी का कोई ऐसा कोई
डाउट
है टास्क यह है आपको क्या करना है मैंने
आपको नेट बायस पढ़ा रहा हूं नेट बायस होता
क्या है और कैसे काम करता है उसका
इंट्रोडक्शन मैंने आपको प्रोवाइड किया है
ऐसे एसएमबी को मैं बताऊंगा कि एसएमबी होता
क्या है और क्या काम किया क्या काम है
इसका लेकिन आपका काम क्या है कि एसएमबी
कैसे काम करता बिहाइंड द सीन कि कैसे यह
एक डिवाइस से दूसरे डिवाइस प कम्युनिकेट
करते हैं कैसे हैंड करते जैसे मैंने अभी
आपको दिखाया ना कि नेम सर्विस रेजोल्यूशन
कैसे किया वा एकसार में आपको दिखाया इसी
तरीके से एसएमबी भी काम करता है और इसी
तरीके से नेट वॉइस भी काम करता है तो इनके
ऊपर आपको डिटेल रिसर्च करनी है और खुद का
आर्टिकल लिखना है और व आर्टिकल आपको
लिंकडन में पोस्ट करने हैं और इसमें डे
फोनिक्स और सचिन मेरे को दोनों को क्या
करना है टैग करना है और मैं देखता हूं कि
कितने स्टूडेंट उसको पोस्ट करते हैं टैक
करते हैं हो जाएगा
अगर आपके पास आईपी एड्रेस नहीं और ना ही
आपके पास होस्ट नेम है तो आप उस मशीन तक
ही नहीं पहुंच
पाओगे चलो अभी एसएमबी होता क्या है एसएमबी
के बारे में बात करते हैं एसएमबी होता है
सर्वर मैसेज ब्लॉक इज ए नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल
यूज्ड फॉर फाइल शेयरिंग प्रिंटर्स एंड अदर
रिसोर्सेस बिटवीन कंप्यूटर्स विद इन ए
नेटवर्क इट अलाउ एप्लीकेशंस एंड सिस्टम्स
टू कम्युनिकेट ओवर ए लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क
और ए वाइड एरिया नेटवर्क एसएमबी इज
प्राइमर यूज्ड इन माइक्रोसॉफ्ट विंडोज
सिस्टम बट इज आल्सो सपोर्टेड बाय अदर
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लाइक
[संगीत]
के अंदर यूज किया जाता है लेकिन आजकल क्या
है
करने के लिए डायरेक्ट कम्युनिकेशन करने के
लिए टीसीपी आईपी कम्युनिकेशन अगर वो नेट
वायस का यूज कर रहा है तो उस केस में आपको
पोर्ट 44 445 और 139 दोनों पोर्ट्स का
क्या करना यूज मिलेगा ओके अभी जो सांबा
सांबा इज द
सांबा इज द ओपन सोर्स इंप्लीमेंटेशन ऑफ
एसएमबी फॉर लिनेक्स सिस्टम बेसिकली मैं
आपको बताना चाह रहा हूं कि एसएमबी एक
प्रोटोकॉल है जो विंडोज के लिए लेकिन
सांबा उसका ओपन सोर्स इंप्लीमेंटेशन है
एसएमबी का
शेयर करते हो कि एक प्रिंटर को आप 10 पीसी
15 पीसी या 5 पीसी से क्या कर सकते हो एक
साथ प्रिंट दे सकते हो मतलब कहने का मतलब
कहीं एक कहीं पर बैठे होगे तो बैठे-बैठे
क्या कर सकते हो कि हां प्रिंटर किसी ऑफिस
में रखा होगा डायरेक्टली आप प्रिंट दे
सकते हो या आप क्या कर लोगे शेयर फोल्डर
क्रिएट करते हो और अपनी फाइल को तुरंत
बार-बार क्या करोगे आप एक पेन ड्राइव को
लोगे उसके बाद उसके अंदर इंसर्ट करोगे फिर
फाइल शेयर करोगे ये करने के बा डायरेक्टली
एक शेयर फोल्डर क्रिएट करते हो और वो शेयर
फोल्डर क्या कर एक्सेसिबल रहता है वहां पर
बेसिकली बेसिकली क्या वहां पर क्या है
किसका यूज किया जाता है एसएमबी का एसएमबी
प्रोटोकॉल का य यूज किया जाता है ये सारी
चीजें करने के लिए भले ही आपको आपने कामने
काम किया भी होगा और आपने ये चीज नोटिस
नहीं की होगी या किसी ने आपको बताया नहीं
होगा कि कि जब आप फाइल शेयर करते हो या
प्रिंटर शेयर करते हो तो वहां पर किस
टेक्नोलॉजी या किस प्रोटोकॉल यूज किया
जाता है तो वहां पर यूज किया जाता है आपके
एसएमबी का रियल सिनेरियो है ये ये सच में
यूज होते हैं ये कोई ऐसा नहीं है आप बड़ी
किसी भी ऑफिस में काम करो किने किया भी
होगा
तो वहां पर डेफिनेटली आप क्या करते हो
प्रिंटर शेयरिंग करते हो नहीं तो कई बार
आपने देखा है कई बार आप कैफे में जाते हो
तो कैफे में क्या होता है कि कैफे में
जाते हो तो आपके कैफे में आठ पीसी होते
हैं तो किसी भी ब पीसी से बैठ के आप क्या
डायरेक्टली एक प्रिंटर पर प्रिंट दे सकते
हो हाउ इज पॉसिबल वो पॉसिबल है आपके
एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल के थ्रू वहां पर भी क्या
एसएमबी का यूज किया जाता है आपके प्रिंटर
को शेयर करने के लिए समझ में आया एवरीवन
गट क्लियर तो दिस इज द यूज केस ऑफ द
अब इसी चीज का हम क्या करेंगे फायदा
उठाएंगे कि ये जो प्रोटोकॉल्स है यह जो
सर्विसेस है अगर रन कर रही है किसी भी
मशीन के ऊपर और उस नेटवर्क के अंदर हम हैं
या उस नेटवर्क का हमें एक्सेस मिल गया तो
हम उसके ऊपर कैसे फिर एन्यूमरेशन कर सकते
हैं एवरीवन गट क्लियर और एसएमबी कैसे कैसे
काम करता है बिहाइंड द सीन कैसे वो एक
डिवाइस से दूसरे डिवाइस से कम्युनिकेट
करते हैं यह आपका टास्क है क् रिक्वेस्ट
है रिस्पांस में क्या मिलता है फिर यह
उसका रिस्पांस देता है फिर सर्वर से फिर
रिस्पांस मिलता है तो वह किस तरीके से काम
कर सकता है किस किस तरीके से काम करता है
यह आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है एसएमबी के
वर्जन अभी तीन है 1.0 2.0 और 3.0 जैसे 3.1
अभी चल रहा है रिसेंटली 3.1.1 चल रहा है
अभी जो इंक्रिप्शन का यूज करता है ए 128 ए
और ए 256 का यूज करता है सा 512 का यूज
करता है ऑथेंटिकेशन के लिए और एसएमबी के
थ्रू आप कोई भी फाइल या शेयर को एक्सेस
करने के लिए आप क्या करते हो पासवर्ड की
जरूरत पड़ती है आपको यूजर नेम एंड पासवर्ड
की जरूरत पड़ती
है यस कविता
पूछिए प्लीज पूछिए अभी
जल्दी
से बेसिकली क्या है कि नॉर्मली आपको
एसएमबी वन में नहीं मिलेगा नॉर्मली नहीं
मिलेगा उसके लिए प्रोसेस बहुत लंबा है
लेकिन लन में क्या है कि डायरेक्टली कुछ
सर्विसेस है जो बाय डिफॉल्ट आपको क्या
करना पड़े पहली ब सर्विसेस ऑन करनी
पड़ेंगी जैसे सर्वर सर्विसेस होती है आपकी
और और भी कुछ सर्विसेस होती है जो आपके
विंडोज के अंदर आपको जाके ऑन करने पड़ेंगे
उसके बाद आप क्या करोगे अपने जो शेयर्स है
जहां पर आपने एसएमबी से रिलेटेड जो
सर्विसेस उनको डिसेबल किया होगा उनको
इनेबल करने के बाद आप अपने शेयर ऑन कर
सकते हो देन आप डायरेक्टली क्या कर सकते
उसको एक्सेस कर सकते हो वाइड एरिया
नेटवर्क के लिए आपको क्या करनी पड़ेगी
पोर्ट फोर्डिंग करनी पड़ेगी इसको
एक्सेसिबल बनाना पड़ेगा तो उसका प्रोसेस
थोड़ा अलग वाइड एरिया नेटवर्क में नॉर्मली
आपको देखने को नहीं मिलेगा नॉर्मली वाइड ए
नेटवर्क में एसएमबी का केस नहीं देखने का
मिलेगा आपको लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क में
डेफिनेटली देखने को मिलेगा
आपको डेफिनेटली देखने को 100% मिले लेकिन
लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क मिलता ही मिलता है हर
कोई आजकल क्या कि क्योंकि अब एक कंपनी में
100 पीसी है 10 पीसी है तो हर कोई किसी के
पीसी पर जाकर खड़ा नहीं हो सकता ना तो
इसलिए वो क्या है प्रिंटर शेयरिंग के लिए
या लोकल फाइल शेयर के लिए यूज करते
हैं चलो प्रैक्टिकल्स करें अभी नेट वायस
और एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन
का
करें एवरीवन रेडी
अ डिपेंड करता है कि एसबी का कौन सा वर्जन
यूज हो रहा है समझ रहे हो उसके ऊपर क्या
अभी 3.1 यूज कर रहे होंगे तो वह टिपिकल है
क्योंकि वह इंक्रिप्शन का यूज करता
है अगर उसके अंदर कोई वलने बिलिटी है तो
डेफिनेटली आप उसको एक्सप्लोइट कर सकते हो
अग वो लबल नहीं है तो उसको एक्सप्लोइट
नहीं कर सकते वो टी आपको फाइंड आउट करनी
होगी लेकिन लेटेस्ट 3.1 है व अभी वल्नरेबल
नहीं है क्योंकि वो ऑथेंटिकेशन के लिए सा
512 का यूज करता है सा 512 हैच का यूज
करता है जिसको क्या कर सकते हो क्रैक करना
बहुत मुश्किल है मतलब इंपॉसिबल ही
है मे भी डॉक्टर कविता जो आपका नाम तो
आपका डाउट क्लियर हुआ यू गट योर आंसर
नहीं मैं आपका सवाल नहीं समझा सर इ देर
एनी ट्रिक ी शुड एंटर मोर देन टू आईपी इन
नेप एंड गेट ओस इंफॉर्मेशन ओ एन मैप हां ट
आईपी नहीं आप क्या कर सकते हो मल्टी
मल्टीपल आईपी एक साथ ऐड कर सकते हो कॉमा
सेपरेटेड करके आप मल्टीपल आईपी को दे सकते
हो जब आप एक काम करते हो पूरी रेंज दे
सकते हो आईपी एड्रेस की तो आप पूरे सबनेट
दे सकते हो तो आप मल्टीपल आईपी एड्रेस को
भी दे सकते हो शायद मैंने आपको बताया भी
था क्लास में कहीं पर मैंने जिक्र किया था
कि अगर आपको मल्टीपल आईपी एड्रेसस को क्या
करना है एज ए टारगेट देना तो भी आप दे
सकते
हो तो हम प्रैक्टिकली करते हैं अभी मेरे
पास दो मशीने हैं एक नक्स मशीन है एक
विंडोज मशीन है ओके एक नक् और एक विंडोज
है और आज हम यूज करेंगे काली लिनेक्स का
ओके आज हम यूज करेंगे काली लिनेक्स
सबको स्क्रीन दिखाई दे रही
है आपको मैं एक दिन आप एक काम करना आप
मेरे को ज क्लास खत्म हो जाती है उसके बाद
आप मेरे को क्या करना एक बार इसमें कमेंट
सेक्शन में सेम क्वेश्चन पूछना तो मैं
उसमें आपको कमेंट में रिप ला में वो कमांड
भेज दूंगा ओके अभी हम सेशन को कवर करते
हैं ओके जूम करूंगा जूम करूंगा डोंट
वरी
यस अभी मेरे पास दो मशीने है एक नक्स मशीन
है और एक विंडोज सर्वर है तो मुझे क्या
करना सबसे पहले मैं क्या करूंगा नेट बायस
एन्यूमरेशन करूंगा मैं क्या करूंगा सबसे
पहले नेट बायोस एन्यूमरेशन करूंगा तो नेट
बायोस एमेशन के लिए मुझे क्या करना सबसे
पहले फाइंड आउट करता हूं एन मैप उसके बाद
हाइन पी एन उसके बाद हाइन एसवी रहा
181 और दूसरा मेरा क्या
[संगीत]
है ड
182 ड 182 यह रहा आपका आंसर भी हो जाएगा
अभी दोनों पर मैं क्या कर रहा हूं फाइंड
आउट कर रहा हूं हिट एंटर
एक मिनट मे सम विश विद
ट वन मशीन मशीन जो मेरी है उसके साथ कुछ
इशू हो रहा है तो उसको मैं एक बार
रीस्टार्ट कर देता
हूं इट विल टेक टाइम तो तब तक मैं क्या
करता हूं विंडोज मशीन को यूज करेंगे
हम तो अभी मैं इसको ओनली अकेली मशीन को कर
रहा हूं इस तरीके से आप दे सकते हो रेंज
रेंज 181 से 182 किया मैंने अभी
न 81 नहीं चाहिए मुझे 2 22
चाहिए यह
रहा तो सबसे पहले मैं फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश कर रहा हूं कि क्या ये सर्विसेस जो
मैं नेट वायस एन्यूमरेशन करना है क्या जो
138 137 और 139 क्या मेरे टारगेट के ऊपर
जो टारगेट सिस्टम है उसके ऊपर रनिंग भी है
या नहीं है सबसे पहले मुझे कंफर्म करना है
और और ये भी कंफर्म कर लेता हूं क्या
टारगेट एक्टिव है या अभी वो भी नहीं है
192 व ओके
नाउ हिट
एंटर यह मैं पिंग कर रहा हूं ओके पिंग का
रिस्पांस आ रहा है
मेरा यह रहा
आप खुद का लैब सेटअप करना पड़ेगा
आपको अभी के लिए लेकिन आने वाले टाइम में
अगर अभी सीखना है तो आने वाले टाइम में
आपको मैं लैब्स दूंगा उसमें आप परफॉर्म कर
सकते हो और अभी मैं आपको बता दूंगा य क
प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो बताऊंगा मैं आपको
समथिंग इशू विद माय
मशीन ओके वो भी मशीन मेरी पावर ऑफ
होगी
वेट ओके इज इट वर्किंग
नाउ
पिंग हां अनरीचेबल
तो ना 181 पर करते हैं तब तक तो अभी वह
हमारा चलो अभी मेरी मशीन एक्टिव हो रही है
ओके कोई इशू
नहीं होस्ट डिस्कवरी कर रहे हैं भैया अभी
हम पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करेंगे हमें होस्ट
डिस्कवरी क्यों करनी है अभी जब मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं कि मेरे पास होस्ट है
दो अभी हम चेक कर लेते हैं ना एक बार यह
रहा यस मशीन इज अप
नाउ अभी हम करेंगे एन
मैप ये रहा
तक हम क्या करते हैं दूसरी मशीन पर टाइम
सेव करने के लिए एन मैप हाइन प एन देन
उसके बाद सर्विस वर्जन 181 इस पर भी कर
लेते हैं साथ के साथ दोनों मशीन पर हम रन
कर देते हैं एन मैप
नहीं मैंने आपको बताया
[संगीत]
ना कुमावत कि आप रेंज में स्पेसिफाई कर दो
या कॉमा सेपरेटेड दो आईपी एड्रेस दे सकते
हो अभी हमारे प्रैक्टिकल्स में थोड़ा
थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा तो मे भी मुझे लगता है
आज की क्लास में ओनली नेट बायस एन्यूमरेशन
ही हो पाएगा प्रैक्टिकली और शायद में भी
नेक्स्ट क्लास में हमें एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन
प्रैक्टिकली करना होगा देखिए अभी यह क्या
बता रहा है 21 टीसीपी ओपन 228 445 336 अभय
कुछ शो ही नहीं कर रहा ट द इशू वि
ट इस मशीन के साथ थोड़ा सा इशू हो रहा है
दूसरे वाली मशीन के साथ बार इट विल क्रैश
कर रही है बारबार क्रैश कर रही है
हो
हो यस देखिए अभी हम देखते हैं य रिजल्ट है
देखो यह रहा ये है मेरा 192
1680 अभी यहां पर देखो टीसी 2 से मुझे कोई
मतलब नहीं है मुझे मतलब है देखो पट
135 139 और 445 अभी 139 एंड 135 पोर्ट ठीक
है तो ये क्या है मेरा विंडोज आरपीसी और
यह क्या है मेरा 139 ओपन नेट बायस एसस ओके
139 नेट बायस ओपन तो 138 भी ओपन नहीं है
यहां पर 137 भी क्यों नहीं है होना तो
चाहिए था
तो एक काम करते हैं अभी हमें नेट बर्स
करना ओनली तो एक काम करते हैं अभी
स्पेसिफिकली हम फोकस करते हैं पोर्ट के
ऊपर तो एन मैप
हाइन एस यू यूडीपी पोर्ट ओनली टीसीपी शो
कर ना हाइन सर्विस स्कैन देन उसके बाद हम
क्या करते हैं हाइन पोर्ट अभी मैं रेंज
मेंशन कर देते हैं
हम हाइन प हाइन प अब मुझे अभी कौन सी
चाहिए यूडीपी
पोर्ट एक तो मैं यूडीपी पोर्ट कर रहा हूं
देन
137 क्रॉस चेक करने के लिए 138 देन उसके
बाद
कॉमा टीसीपी पोर्ट मेंशन करता हूं मैं
इसमें 137
139 137
और कमा 139
139 देन उसके बाद मैं मेंशन करता हूं
192.168 ये रहा और डायरेक्टली स्कैनिंग
परफॉर्म करता है इन पोर्ट्स के ऊपर ओपन है
क्लोज है देखिए यह रहा 137 फिल्टर्ड पोर्ट
है 139 ओपन है 137 यूडीपी जो पोर्ट है ओपन
है और 138 ओपन और फिल्टर्ड ओके ओपन एंड
नेट ये इतनी इंफॉर्मेशन हमें मिली अभी मैं
एक काम करता हूं इसके ऊपर भी सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन परफॉर्म करता हूं साथ के साथ साथ
के साथ क्या करता हूं आन एसवी सर्विस
वर्जन भी कर ले वर्जन डिटेक्शन भी कर लेता
हूं यह देखिए
य पर सारी चीज टाइम लेंगी इट विल टेक
टाइम आज मैं आपको बताऊंगा एक और चीज है
मैं आपको बताऊंगा जो भी स्क्रिप्ट हम यूज
करने वाले हैं एनएससी स्क्रिप्ट ये आपकी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है एनएससी स्क्रिप्ट को
एक्सप्लोर करना उसके बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
प्राप्त करना कि ये एनएससी स्क्रिप्ट करती
क्या है क्योंकि हर एक स्क्रिप्ट को मैं
एक्सप्लेन नहीं कर सकता मैं आपके सामने
यूज करूंगा और आपका काम है उसको एक्सप्लोर
करना एक्सप्लोर करके उस स्क्रिप्ट को एज ए
नोट्स आप खुद से अपने पास रखिए कभी भी आप
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करोगे कभी भी आप
एनमने करोगे या चाहे आप कुछ भी करोगे अपनी
किसके अंदर सर्टिफिकेशन के अंदर कहीं पर
भी तो आपको काफी हेल्पफुल होंगे वेरी वेरी
हेल्पफुल अभी देखिए यहां पर 137 फिल्टर्ड
मतलब आप समझ जाइए 139 टीसीपी पोर्ट नेट बस
ए
इंफॉर्मेशन मतलब आपको काफी हेल्पफुल
इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पर आपको मिल गई अभी मैं
एक काम कर सकता हूं बैनर ग्रबिंग भी कर
सकता हूं बैनर इंफॉर्मेशन कैसे वो भी आपको
पता है कि देखिए क्या अगर मुझे पहले पता
करना है कि एन मैप और हाइन हाइन स्क्रिप्ट
सी आर आई पीटी स्क्रिप्ट हाइन
हेल्प उसके बाद इक्वल बैनर इक्वल बैनर यह
काम क्या करता है यह एनएस स्क्रिप्ट देखिए
इसके बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन पढ़िए कैटेगरी
क्या है डिस्कवरी सेफ ए सिंपल बैनर
ग्रैबिंग व्हिच कनेक्ट टू द पोर्ट्स ए चच
पोर्ट य क्लियर नहीं हो रहा प्रिंट
आउट एनीथिंग सेंट बाय द लिसनिंग सर्विस
विदन फ सेकंड द बैनर विल टन केटेड टू फिट
इनटू अ सिंगल लाइन बट एन एक्स्ट्रा लाइन
मे बी मे बी प्रिंटेड फॉर एवरी इंक्रीज
एवरी इंक्रीज इन द लेवल ऑफ वर्बोसिटी
रिक्वेस्टेड ऑन द कमांड लाइन आप क्या
करोगे कि बैनर का क्या मतलब है कि जब भी
आप किसी सर्विस से कनेक्ट होने की कोशिश
करते तो वहा पर आपको कोई ना कोई बैनर
देखने को मिलता है तो अभी मैं क्या करूंगा
स्क्रिप्ट को यूज करने वाला हूं एम
हाइन हाइन प एनम हाइन पोर्ट यूज करने वाला
तो य सारी चीज यूज करता हूं एक बार मैं
सारी सर्विसेस यूज करके ओके
हाइन एस यू उसके बाद
हाइन एस ए उसके बाद
हाइन सर्विस वर्जन भी यूज करता हूं देन
हान हान हान स्क्रिप्ट हा हाइन स्क्रिप्ट
इक्वल
मैनर देन उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
11680 222 यह देखिए एंड पोर्ट मैंने मेंशन
किए नहीं यहां पर तो मैं अभी एक काम कर
देता हूं यहां पर पोर्ट नंबर भी मेंशन कर
देता हूं यह रहा तो ये सारे के सारे पोर्ट
नंबर
हाइन
प यह रहा तोय पोर्ट कौन से है यहां पर वे
इज माय
पोर्ट दज आर द
पोर्ट्स यह र
हिट
एंटर सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा है समझ में
आ रहा है क्या चल रहा है क्योंकि एन मैप
आप सबको आता है एन मैप में ये एनएससी क्या
होता है एन मैप स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन क्या
होता है मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन कर चुका हूं
यहां पर कुछ स्क्रिप्ट है जो आपको अभी साथ
के साथ पता चलेंगे ये स्क्रिप्ट का रोल
क्या है अब बैनर स्क्रिप्ट का क्या मतलब
है यह आपको खुद से और भी आइडेंटिफिकेशन
ओके हो
जाएगा या रिप्लाई तो
कीजिए ऊपर से जा रहा है
बताइए जब तक यह होरहा हम एक काम करते हैं
मैं आपको एक चीज दिखा देता हूं अगर आपको
नेट बायस की प्रैक्टिस करनी है या जो भी
अभी कुछ क्लासेस में करवा रहा हूं तो आप
एक काम कर सकते ट्राई हैक मी पर जाना है
और ट्राई हैक मी पर आप एक काम करोगे
प्रैक्टिस करने के लिए आपके पास है यह
रहा ये की एसएमबी
एन्यूमरेशन ये रहा यहां पर क्या कर सकते
हो यह वाली एक नेटवर्क सर्विस से रिलेटेड
फ्री है यह आप इसको जवाइन कर सकते हो अंड
एसएमबी क्या होता है उस कैसे नरेट करना है
कैसे एक्सट करना है यह तीन टास्क टू टास्क
वन टास्क टू टास्क थ्री टास्क फोर यह
तीनों चारों चारों आप क्या कर सकते हो
प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो परचेज इसको परचेज
करने की जरूरत नहीं है फ्री है यह फ्री है
इसके लिए प्रीमियम वर्जन नहीं चाहिए आपको
देखिए गेटिंग स्टार्टेड एसएमबी होता क्या
है कैसे एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म करते हैं यहां
पर आप सारे काम कर सकते हो जो मैं आपको
सिखाऊंगा एसएमबी में नेट वायस भी यहां पर
कर जो एसएमबी है तो इसमें नेट वायस
डेफिनेटली मिलेगा तो आप नेट वायस वाली
कमांड यहां रन करके देख सकते हो टेलनेट पे
आप खुद से कर लेना और एफटीपी मैं आपको
बताऊंगा एफटीपी भी आप यहां से कर लेना ओके
तो आपको मैं बता दिया कंप्लीट रूम आप खुद
से करोगे तो आपको वेरी वेरी हेल्प मिलेगी
इसको मतलब काफी हेल्पफुल रहेगा आपके
लिए तो काम करते हैं ये रहा हो गया
कंप्लीट
अभी यहां पर क्या इंफॉर्मेशन मिली हमें
कुछ ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन तो मिली नहीं
फिल्टर्ड पोर्ट 137 139 बैनर्स में वही
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली कुछ ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन
मिली नहीं लेकिन आपको काफी हेल्पफुल हो
सकता है यह वाला
यह कौन सी स्क्रिप्ट कुछ और स्क्रिप्ट
होती है जैसे कि मैं आपको बता दूं अगर कुछ
एक स्क्रिप्ट होती है मैं आपको एक काम बता
देता हूं मैंने आपको कौन-कौन सी कमांड अभी
यूज की थी आपके सामने लिखने की वैसे जरूरत
तो नहीं है जैसे कि एक रहा है कि ए मैप
सेम यह वाली ए मैप हान हान एयू हाफ हान
सर्विस सर्विस स्कैन सील स्कैन सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन बैनर अभी कुछ स्क्रिप्ट
होती है जैसे व कौन सी स्क्रिप्ट है
देखिए चार स्क्रिप्ट है एकएक करके मैं
आपको दिखाता हूं नहीं तो आप एक साथ भी यूज
कर सकते हो इसके ऊपर अभी जैसे कौन-कौन से
स्क्रिप्ट है मैं आपको बता देता हूं अभी
अभी अभी य काम एक तो होती है एनबी स्टेट
एनबी स्टेट कमा एक होती है
एनबी डी
हाइन एनबीडी हाइन इंफो एनबीडी हाइन इंफो
एक होती है
ब्रॉडकास्ट ब्रॉडकास्ट एक साथ सबको यूज कर
रहा ब्रॉडकास्ट
हाइन नेट बायोस हाई फन
मास्टर हाइ फन
ब्राउजर ब्राउजर उसके बाद एक होती
है
एनबीएनएस नेट बायस नेम
सर्विस
इंटरफेस
इंटरफेस आई एन टीई आरस सीई एस फेसेस ओके
यह रही कौन-कौन सी है एनबी स्टेट
एनबीडी इंफो एक तो फ थर्ड आपकी ब्रॉडकास्ट
नेट वॉइस मास्टर ब्राउजर और एनबीएनएस
इंटरफेस अब स्क्रिप्ट क्याक काम करती है
इनके बारे में अगर जानना है तो एक काम
करते हैं हम ए मैप आप क्या कर सकते हो हान
न स्क्रिप्ट हाइन देखो एनबी एनएस इंटरफेस
क्या करती है
देखिए रिट्रीव आईपी एड्रेस ऑफ द टारगेट
नेटवर्क इंटरफेस वाया नेट बायस नेम सर्विस
ओके वाया नेट नेम सर्विस एडिशनल नेटवर्क
इंटरफेस मे बी रिवील मोर इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट
द टारगेट इंक्लूडिंग फाइंडिंग पाथ टू हिडन
नॉन रोटेड नेटवर्क्स वाया मल्टी होम
सिस्टम तो इस सेल्फ एक्सप्लेनेटरी है यह
सारी बिल्कुल आपको समझ में आ जाएंगी अभी
मैं उसके बाद नेक्स्ट मैं आपको बता देता
हूं
एनबी
स्टेट देखिए यह क्या करती है बाय डिफॉल्ट
यह क्या यह करती है अटम टू रिट्रीव द
टारगेट नेट बायोस नेट बायोस नेम एंड मैक
एड्रेस यह नेम मैक एड्रेस बाय डिफॉल्ट दिस
स्क्रिप्ट डिस्प्ले द नेम ऑफ द कंप्यूटर
एंड द लगड इन
यूजर इफ वर्बोसिटी इज टर्न अप इट डिस्प्ले
ऑल नेम्स एंड सिस्टम थिंग्स इट ओनस ओके
अगर एक और चीज है अगर मैं दूसरे वाली अग
आपको चेक करनी है
ए एनबीडी एनबीडी हाइन इंफो इस तरीके से आप
पता कर सकते स्क्रिप्ट क्या करती है देखो
यह रही द नेट वायस ब्लॉक डिवाइस प्रोटोकॉल
इज यूज टू पब्लिश ब्लॉक डिवाइस ओवर टीसीपी
दिस स्क्रिप्ट कनेक्ट टू एन एनबीडी सर्वर
एंड अटेंप्ट टू पुल डाउन ए लिस्ट ऑफ
एक्सपोर्टेड ब्लॉक डिवाइसेज एंड देयर
डिटेल्स ओके डिस्प्ले प्रोटोकॉल्स एंड
ब्लॉक डिवाइस इंफॉर्मेशन और भी एडिशनल
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए तो गेट अप पे जाके साइ
इंफॉर्मेशन गेटन कर सकते हो तो ये आपको
मैंने बता दिया ये चार स्क्रिप्ट एक् साथ
हम रन करेंगे इसके अंदर और आपको देखते हैं
कि व्हाट टाइप ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन यू विल गेट
और हाइ फन वर्बोसिटी हम इसको यूज करते हैं
अबकी बार हिट एंटर यह
देखिए लोडेड 50 स्क्रिप्ट्स को स्कैनिंग
स्क्रिप्ट प्री स्कैनिंग इनिला इजिंग
एनएससी एट 20119 यह देखो अभी देखते रहो
व्ट टाइप इंफॉर्मेशन यू विल
गेट क्यों इसको मैं क्यों यूज करूंगा यार
मुझे सभी स्क्रिप्ट की लिस्ट आउट थोड़ना
करना यार वह आपका काम है उसको आप गेट इन
कीजिए आप ही उसको फाइंड आउट कीजिए मैं तो
आपको डायरेक्टली स्क्रिप्ट बता रहा हूं कि
यह स्क्रिप्ट इस परपस से यूज की जाती है
यह यूज की जाती है यह आप कई बार सीटीएस
में भी देखोगे और रियल उसमें भी आप देखोगे
सिनेरियो में यूज की जाती है य इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट करने के लिए नरेशन करने के लिए
तो मैं आपको सीधा डायरेक्टली वो बता रहा
हूं ये आपका काम उसको फाइंड आउट करना
66 पर हुआ अभी तक
ओके यह देखिए व्ट टाइप ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन इट
विल प्रोवाइड इंग देखिए यहां पर अभी ऊपर
से नीचे चलते हैं
नाउ फिल्टर्ड ओपन
ओपन एंड वर्क ग्रुप इसका क्या है वर्क
ग्रुप एनबीएनएस इंटरफेस देखो होस्ट नेम
क्या है आपको पहले भी पता था अभी क्लियर
आपको पता चल गया दिस इज द होस्ट नेम वगें
2008 ओके
इंटरफेस 22 एंड 169.254
255 देरर टू इंटरफेस ऑन द मशीन इस मशीन के
ऊपर दो इंटरफेस है यूडीपी ओपन फिल्टर
पोर्ट्स यही सर्विस इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
प्रोवाइड कर रही है ओस कौन सा है नाउ अभी
यहां पर देखिए नेट बायस नेम क्या है इसका
एनबी स्टेटस नेट बायस नेम क्या है वर
ग्रेंट वे ग्रेंट 2008 आ2 नेट बॉयस यूजर
अननोन नहीं पता मैक एड्रेस ये रहा दिस इज
द मैक एड्रेस ऑफ द मशीन ओके ओरेकल वर्चुअल
बॉक्स वर्चुअल एनईसी नाउ यह देख नेम्स
अभी वेगें 2008 आ2 वर्क ग्रुप ग्रेंट 200
दे लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन दे आर प्रोवाइड मी
देखिए फ्लक्स यूनिक ग्रुप यूनिक अभी ये
देखो
जी क्या होती है मैं आपको बताऊंगा इनका एक
कोड होता है यूनिक और ग्रुप का क्या मतलब
होता है उसके बाद
देखिए एनएससी प स्कैनिंग इनिला इजिंग
एनएससी व्ट एवर देखो आपको यह सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली होस्ट नेम आपके पास है
इंटरफेस पर क्या क्या आईपी एड्रेस आपको
पता चल गया कौन सी मशीन यूज हो रही है और
इन तीनों पोर्ट्स के थ्रू और इसके अंदर
कौन सा वर्क ग्रुप है क्योंकि शेयर क्रिएट
हुए हैं क्योंकि इसके ऊपर क्या है जो
विंडोज सिस्टम है जो विंडोज सर्वर है 2008
इसके ऊपर शेयर क्रिएट हो रखे हैं तो ये
उनकी इंफॉर्मेशन है ये शेयर्स क्रिएट कौन
से बाय डिफॉल्ट वाले हैं क्योंकि अगर आपको
ज्यादा डिटेल्स में जाना है तो विंडोज की
इंटरनल नेटवर्किंग सिस्टम के बारे में
आपको इंफॉर्मेशन होनी चाहिए और शायद मुझे
नहीं पता यहां पर किसी को भी विंडोज
इंटरनल नेटवर्किंग सिस्टम कैसे विंडो काम
कर सकता है कौन-कौन सी सर्विसेस उसके लिए
रिस्पांसिबल होती है और बाय डिफॉल्ट जब भी
आपको शेयर ऑन करते हैं को पर्टिकुलर
सर्विस ऑन करते हैं तो बाय डिफॉल्ट आपको
कुछ शेयर्स हो वो हमेशा देखने को क्यों
मिलते हैं तो वो चीजें आपकी इंटरनल विंडोज
इंटरनल नेटवर्क जो होता है ना उसको उससे
ही सीखने को मिलती है
नाउ यह आपको मैंने बता दिया तो इस नेट
बायस नरेशन में आप क्या कर सकते हो बैनर
स्क्रिप्ट का यूज कर सकते हो या यूज कर
सकते हो एनबी स्टेट एनबीडी इंफो
ब्रॉडकास्ट नेट वॉइस मास्टर ब्राउजर एनबी
एनबीएस इंटरफेस इन स्क्रिप्ट का क्या कर
सकते हो आप यूज कर सकते हो शायद आप लोगों
को मिल गई होगी पता होगा नहीं यह य इस
तरीके देखो मैंने आपको बताया था कॉपी करता
हूं अगर आपके पास आ जाएगी तो आपको सेंड कर
देता
हूं और ब्लॉक कर दिया तो आई कांट से देखिए
इसको कॉपी करके रख लीजिए आप अपने हिसाब से
इसको मॉडिफाई कर लेना और उससे पहले वाली
भी स्क्रिप्ट मैं आपके पास भेज देता हूं
यह बैनर वाली यह
रही ओ
शट यह रही मैं इसको कॉपी कर रहा था ब कॉपी
और कुछ हो
गया यह
रहा यह रहा दोनों मिल गया
आपको तो आपको उसके नोट्स बना के रखने
पड़ेंगे
देखिए मैं आपको एन्यूमरेशन करवा रहा तो
एनमने में आपको वोव स्क्रिप्ट बता रहा हूं
जो यूज की जाती हैं कक उनसे इंफॉर्मेशन
मिलती है अब जैसे जैसे आपको एक्सपीरियंस
होगा जैसे जैसे आपको विंडोज की नेटवर्किंग
या विंडोज के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन होगी
लिनक्स कैसे काम करता है जैसे जैसे आप आगे
जाओगे आपको पता होगा कि ओके मुझे क्याक
इंफॉर्मेशन मेरे लिए हेल्पफुल है तो यह
स्क्रिप्ट यह इंफॉर्मेशन आपको प्रोवाइड
करती है तो मैं आपको मोस्ट पॉपुलर
स्क्रिप्ट जो ज्यादातर यूज की जाती है मैं
उसकी लिस्ट आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं
ये रहा अभी एक और चीज है आपको मैंने बता
दिया अभी एक कमांड होती है इसके अंदर
आपके य
एक यह रहा एक टूल्स है उस टूल का भी आप
यूज कर सकते हो वो टूल का काम टूल का नाम
है एनएमबी लुक अप एनएमबी लुक अप एनएमबी
लुक अप उसके बाद हाइन हाइन हेल्प फाइल
उसकी देखोगे तो आपको देखने को मिल जाएगी
इसकी हेल्प फाइल है एक टूल्स है इसका भी
आप यूज कर सकते हो लेकिन आपको अभी समझ में
नहीं टूल क्या काम करता है तो उसके बारे
में काम करते हैं अभी क्लियर कर देता हूं
तो मेन पेज पढ़ते हैं इसका
एनएमबी लुक अप एक टूल का यूज किया था
देखिए एनएमबी लुकअप टूल का काम क्या
डिस्क्रिप्शन दिस टूल इज अ पार्ट ऑफ सांबा
सूट ठीक है एनएमबी लुकअप इज यूज टू क्यूरी
नेट बायोस नेम्स एंड मैप देम टू आईपी
एड्रेसस इन ए नेटवर्क यूजिंग नेट बायस ओवर
टीसीपी आईपी क्यूरीज द ऑप्शन अलाउ द नेम
क्यूरीज टू बी डायरेक्टेड एट ए पर्टिकुलर
आईपी ब्रॉडकास्ट एरिया और टू ए पर्टिकुलर
मशीन ऑल क्यूरीज आर डन ओवर यूडीपी देखिए
ये क्या करता है कि जो एन एनम एनएमबी
लुकअप जो टूल्स है आपके नेट बायोस का यूज
करता है आपकी क्यूरी को रिजॉल्व करने के
लिए मतलब क्यूरी भेजता है और वहां से उसको
रिजॉल्व करता है उसके बेसिस पर आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करता है ओके आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन वहां पर कौन-कौन सी इंफॉर्मेशन
प्रोवाइड करता है नॉर्मली आपके वर्क ग्रुप
की इंफॉर्मेशन या आपके होस्ट नेम की
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको प्रोवाइड करता है यह इस
टूल की इंफॉर्मेशन है बाकी जितने भी ऑप्शन
इसके अंदर यूज कि जाते हैं उनकी डिटेल
इंफॉर्मेशन इसने बताई है हान r है ट्राई
एंड बाइन टू यूडीपी पोर्ट 137 टू सेंड एंड
रिसीव यूडीपी टू सेंड एंड रिसीव यूडीपी
डाटा ग्राम मतलब य 137 पोर्ट का यूज करेगा
क्या करने के लिए आपके उसको इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग के लिए उसके बाद हान ए हान ए
इंटरप्रेट नेम्स एज एन आईपी एड्रेस एंड डू
ए नोड स्टेटस क्यूरी ऑन दिस एड्रेस तो दे
आर लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन तो हम सिंपली क्या
करते हैं अभी इसका यूज करते हैं इसका मैं
यूज करते हैं
एनएमबी लुक अप अभी फिर ये सवाल हो सर हम
मल्टीपल टूल यूज करते हैं मल्टीपल
स्क्रिप्ट यूज करते हैं याद कैसे याद आप
तभी आपके देखो कोई भी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
का एग्जाम दोगे चाहे वो सीच है ईजी पीएटी
है कोई भी एडवांस एग्जाम है ओससीपी है सब
कुछ है दीज आर ओपन बुक एग्जाम ओपन बुक
एग्जाम का मतलब क्या है कि आप ग का यूज कर
सकते हो आपने देखो आपके आप जब भी क्या कर
जितने भी लैब की प्रैक्टिस करते हो अपनी
लाइफ में जितने भी लैब्स की प्रैक्टिस
करते हो जितने भी कोर्सेस पढ़ते हो हर कोई
कोई ना कोई कमांड कोई ना कोई टूल्स यूज
करता है किसी पर्टिकुलर इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग के लिए तो आप क्या कर सकते हो सभी
की आपकी जरूरत नहीं है लेकिन
आपको एक बार सभी यूज करके देखने हैं
कंपैरिजन करना है कौन सा टूल आपके लिए
बेटर है कौन सा टूल आपके लिए बेटर नहीं है
ब उस टूल की आपको क्या करनी है लिस्ट आउट
करना उसको लिस्ट बनानी है और खुद की एक
डोकेट बोल सकते हैं ना एक मास्टर चीट शीट
बोल सकते हैं वो आपको खुद की मास्टर चीट
शीट रखनी पड़ेगी ओके जब मैं एन्यूमरेशन
परफॉर्म करूंगा तो मेरे पास ऑप्शंस इतने
हैं कि मैं ये ये स्क्रिप्ट यूज कर सकता
हूं लेकिन ये स्क्रिप्ट का रोल आईडिया ले
लो कि ये स्क्रिप्ट ये काम कर क्योंकि जब
उस स्क्रिप्ट के बारे में आप पढ़ोगे जैसे
मैंने बैनर स्क्रिप्ट बताई एनबी स्टेटस
स्क्रिप्ट बताई कि वो आपको नेट बायस नेम
प्लस में मैक एड्रेस प्रोवाइड कर रही है
तोब आपको पता कि इन दो चीजों का आपके रोल
है बाकी आपके पास इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं चाहिए
आपको अगर ज्यादा डीप जाना नहीं है आपको
लगता है मुझे इतनी इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए तो आप
क्या करो उस पर्टिकुलर स्क्रिप्ट को यूज
करो लेकिन आप अपने नोट्स में चाहे वो आपके
गल नोट्स हो चाहे आपके वन नोट में नोट्स
बनाओ चाहे वो हैंड राइटिंग नोट्स हो तो
उसके ऊपर एक रिमार्क्स रखिए कि इस ये
स्क्रिप्ट का मेन मेन परपज बस मोटा-मोटा
परपज रखिए बस ओनली लिख लीजिए कि जैसे आप
क्या करो जब भी पेन टेस्ट करोगे जब भी आप
कोई भी क्या करो सीटीएफ सॉल्व करोगे तो
सीटीएफ सॉल्व करते वक्त आपको ध्यान में
रखना कि ओके कि अभी मैं किस फेज में हूं
और मुझे यहां से क्या कर रहा हूं मैं आप
प्रेजेंस ऑफ माइंड कि मु इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग कर रहा हूं एमेशन कर रहा हूं मेरे
पास इतने पोर्ट्स ओपन है नेट बायस है तो
मुझे इतना पता है कि नेट बायस से मैं
क्या-क्या इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल सकता हूं नेट
बायस से मैं इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल सकता हूं कि
कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम रन कर रहा है और
उसके ऊपर कौन-कौन से शेयर्स हैं कोई
शेयर्स हैं अगर कोई शेयर होगा रीड राइट
टेबल आपको शेयर मिल गया तो वहां पर क्या
कर सकते हो आप खुद की एक बैक डोर प्लांट
कर सकते हो उसके अंदर या कोई ऐसा टूल
प्लांट कर सकते हो जो सिस्टम की वीकनेसेस
को आपको शोकेस करेगा आपको बताएगा तो इस
तरीके से आपको अप्रोच करनी होगी चाहे
ओटीएफ के थ्रू ही सीख सकते हो आप जितने
ज्यादा आप लैब सॉल्व करोगे जितने ज्यादा
खुद की टेक्निक्स होगी जितनी ज्यादा आप
स्क्रिप्ट को यूज करोगे और छोटे-छोटे वहां
पर रिमार्क्स लिखोगे उतना ही ज्यादा आप को
बेनिफिट
होगा आपको रटना नहीं है आपको हमेशा साइड
में रखना है देखो आपको मैं बताया पीसी में
हमेशा बुकमार्क करके रखिए आप हमेशा नोट्स
बना रहे हो तो आप अपने उनको नोट्स को साइड
में रखिए आप देख के सॉल्व करना ना आपको और
जब एक बार जिस स्क्रिप्ट को आप यूज कर
लेते हो आपके पास एक प्री डिफाइंड अप्रोच
होती है डिफाइंड मतलब ओके मुझे सबसे पहले
पिं करना है देन उसके बाद नेक्स्ट स्टेप
है एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग ओके आईपी ये
पोर्ट्स है और मुझे अभी ये टूल ए मैप की
ये स्क्रिप्ट रन कर लेता हूं या ए मैप की
कॉमन स्क्रिप्ट रन कर लेता हूं ओके या
इसके अगेन मैं एसएमबी क्लाइंट यूज कर लेता
हूं ओके यहां पे शेयर मिल गया ठीक है शेयर
को एक्सेस करने की कोशिश करो ओके यहां पर
पासवर्ड है पासवर्ड तो ब्रूट फोर्स करता
हूं ब्रूट फोर्स करने अगर पासवर्ड मिला यस
पासवर्ड मिल गया तो उसको एक्सेस कर लिया
फिर ट्राई करना आपको फिर नेक्स्ट स्टेप
ऐसे काम किया जाता है भाई
ऐसे समझ में आया
तो ये एनएमबी लुकअप है और हा ओके एल एमबी
लुकअप मैं यूज कर रहा था अभी हेल्प फाइल
थी अभी मैं इसको क्या करता हूं हान ए यूज
किया मैंने हान कैपिटल ए देन उसके बाद फॉर
एग्जांपल मेरा
192.168 मैं यूज कर रहा हूं कौन सा 222
यूज कर रहा हू हिट एंटर अभी आपके सामने
सेम इंफॉर्मेशन आ रही है जो ए मैप की
स्क्रिप्ट के थ्रू आया था कि
वेगें 2008 आ2 एक्टिव वर्क ग्रुप जो ग्रुप
है एक्टिव
वेगें 2008 आ2 एक्टिव अभी यह
00002 यह होता क्या है इसका मतलब अभी देखो
मैक एड्रेस मशीन का उस मशीन का मैक एड्रेस
क्या
0827 d7 cd8 आपके पास मैक एड्रेस है होस्ट
नेम है आपके पास वर्क ग्रुप की इंफॉर्मेशन
है समझ रहे हो अगर आप एक ऐसे एनवायरमेंट
में घुस गए जहां पर आपके पास वर्क ग्रुप
भी है मतलब अगर वो डोमेन पीसी है वहां पर
अगर विंडो सर्वर यूज किए जा रहे हैं तो एक
सला नेटवर्क है आपके पास वहां पर होस्ट
नेम है मैक एड्रेस है तो मतलब आप क्या
क्या प्लान कर सकते हो क्या क्या सोच सकते
हो ना अभी मैं आपको लिस्ट बता देता
हूं अब इस लिस्ट को आप एक ध्यान से लिख
लिए इसको आप स्क्रीनशॉट ले
लेना कमांड एक्सटी को ही मैं ओपन कर रहा
हूं यहां पर आपको क्या करना है कि वहां पर
कुछ चीज आपको देखने को मिलेंगी तो जीरो
जीरो देखना पड़ेगा आपने जीरो जीरो देखा तो
जीरो जीरो जो आपने देखा उसका मतलब है एक
मिनट रुको यार ये रहा जो आपने जीरो जीरो
किया जीरो जीरो उसका मतलब है मैं आपको बता
देता हूं उसका मतलब है वर्क स्टेशन सर्विस
मतलब वर्क
स्टेशन सर्विस की इंफॉर्मेशन उसके पास या
आप बोल सकते हो वर्क स्टेशन
नेम वर्क स्टेशन नेम बोल सकते हो या आप
होस्ट नेम भी बोल सकते हो अगर आपको रो
मिला अगर वहां पर 03 है 03 आपको वहां पर
क्या मिलेगी जो इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी विंडोज
मैसेंजर सर्विस की इंफॉर्मेशन
विंडोज
मैसेंजर
मैसेंजर सर्विस की आपको क्या मिल रही है
इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी वहां पर जो नाम मिलेगा
कि वो अगर 06 आपको देखने को मिल रहा है
उधर कोड में तो आपको क्या है
रिमोट एक्सेस
सर्विस सर्विस की इंफॉर्मेशन आपको मिल रही
है अगर आपको वहां पर रो देखने को मिला तो
व क्या है आपको फाइल सर्विस या होस्ट
रिकॉर्ड भी बोल सकते हो आपको क्या मिली
वहां पर फाइल
सर्विस सर्विस की इंफॉर्मेशन या आप उसको
क्या बोल सकते हो होस्ट रिकस्ट होस्ट
रिकॉर्ड भी बोल सकते
हो होस्ट रिकॉर्ड भी बोल सकते हो वो
इंफॉर्मेशन इसकी अभी आपका काम है कि
विंडोज मैसेजर सर्विस का क्या काम होता है
रिमोट एक्सेस सर्विस का क्या काम होता है
फाइल सर्विस का क्या काम होता है ये आपको
खुद से रिसर्च करना होगा क्योंकि इतना
रिसर्च भी आप नहीं करोगे तो फिर आप नहीं
कुछ कर सकते आपको खुद से रिसर्च करना होगा
ठीक है और ये अगर आपको रिसर्च हो जाती है
तो यह भी आपको क्या करना है एज ए पोस्ट
में लिंक न में पोस्ट करना है और डिफरेंस
अकेडमी प्लस मेरे को दोनों को टैग करना है
आप सबको पता अगर 21 आपको य कोड देखने को
मिलता है तो इसको है यह आपके रिमोट एक्सेस
सर्विस क्लाइंट
रिमोट
एक्सेस सर्विस क्लाइंट्स की इंफॉर्मेशन
इधर य उसके बाद अगर यहां पर आपको कोड
मिलना है न बी न बी अगर आपको चाहे कैपिटल
और स्मल हो तो यह आपको इंफॉर्मेशन ब
प्राइमरी डोमेन
कंट्रोलर
प्राइमरी डोमेन कंट्रोलर
आपको नहीं पता य सारी इंफॉर्मेशन कितनी
हेल्पफुल है फॉर ए डोमेन अब डोमेन का मतलब
यहां पर नहीं डीएनएस वाला यह डोमेन होता
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के केस में वहां पर
क्या है प्राइमरी डीएनएस सेकेंडरी डीएनएस
होते हैं डोमेन कंट्रोलर होता व जो सारे
सर्वर को कंट्रोल करता है नडी अगर आपको
नडी देखने को मिल रहा है तो उसका मतलब
मास्टर ब्राउजर अब यह क्या होते हैं यह
आपको खुद से फाइंड आउट करना
होगा मास्टर ब्राउजर यह थी आपकी यूनिक
मतलब जो आप देख रहे थे ना अभी क्या नाम है
मैं आपको बताता हूं स्टार्टिंग में जहां
पर आपको ग्रुप ग्रुप के अलावा खाली या
यूनिक लिखा मिलेगा मैंने आपको जब एन मैप
के थ्रू यूनिक लिखा मिला था और ग्रुप मिला
था तो यूनिक में आपको ये सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
देखने को मिलती है तो ये ये कोड मिलता है
ना 0036 02021 तो इनका मतलब कि ये
इंफॉर्मेशन लेटेड है अगर ग्रुप्स नेम्स की
बात करें अगर वहां पर आपको जी आरओ यूपी
ग्रुप देखने को मिलता है तो ग्रुप में अगर
कोड मिलता आपको कि जीरो अगर आपको ग्रुप
में क्या गड मिलता है जीरो जीरो जीरो जीरो
का मतलब है आपका वर्क स्टेशन सर्विस सेम
है वर्क स्टेशन
सर्विस कॉपी
सिलेक्शन पेस्ट या उसको आप बोल सकते हो
डोमेन
नेम डोमेन नेम भी बोल सकते हो या आप बोल
सकते हो वर्क
ग्रुप वर्क ग्रुप बोल सकते होय आपको देखने
को मिलता है वन सी यहां पर अगर वन सी आपको
देखने को मिलता है इसका मतलब यहां पर क्या
है डोमेन कंट्रोलर डोमेन कंट्रोलर की
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल रही
है डोमेन कंट्रोलर फॉर ए
डोमेन यह भी एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी का केस है
उसके बाद नई अगर आपको देखने को मिलता है
मतलब कितनी हेल्पफुल इंफॉर्मेशन एक छोटी
सी टूल से मिलती है ब्राउजर सर्विस
सिलेक्शन सर्विस इलेक्शन यह मैंने शॉर्ट
फॉर्म दे दी अ आपका काम इसको लबरेट करना
ठीक है अभी एक काम कीजिए इसका स्क्रीनशॉट
लीजिए सभी स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए और एक बार
ले लो तो मुझे बता
देना चैट
में हो गया बताइए
ओके अब मैं इसको क्या करता हूं कंट्रोल
एक्स
यस ओके यह यहां पर देखो जीरो जीरो होस्ट
नेम या वर्क स्टेशन सर्विस य ग्रुप के लिए
जीरो जो क्या है व सेम डोमेन कंट्रोलर या
आप बोल सकते हो वर्क स्टेशन सर्विस वर्क
ग्रुप है जिसका नाम है अभी देखने को मिल
रहा मतलब 20 का मतलब क्या है अभी ये
एक्टिव भी है प्लस इसका रो का मतलब मैंने
क्या बताया था फाइल सर्विस या होस्ट
रिकॉर्ड मतलब होस्ट रिकॉर्ड का भी एक नाम
है अब होस्ट रिकॉर्ड का क्या काम है वो आप
फाइंड आउट करना खुद से तो इतनी सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन इतनी वैल्युएबल इंफॉर्मेशन
आपके ये एक छोटा सा टूल प्रोवाइड करता है
एनएमबी लुकअप और इसकी डिटेल इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको पढ़ाया था अभी मेन पेज में अभी आज का
सेशन हम यहीं पर कंप्लीट करेंगे और
नेक्स्ट क्लास होगी डे आफ्टर टुमारो
जिसमें हमारा जो प्रैक्टिकल सेशन बच गया
एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन नेट वायस नमरे में भी
दो टूल्स के बारे में और बताना रह गया
उसके बाद हम फिर शिफ्ट करेंगे एसएमबी
एन्यूमरेशन में तो जो नेक्स्ट सेशन बच गया
आपका टोटली प्रैक्टिकल सेशन बच गया है
एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन का ओनली प्रैक्टिकल
सेशन ऑफ एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन बच गया जिसमें
हम
बाद हम पढ़ेंगे माय स्कल एन्यूमरेशन
एसएनएमपी एन्यूमरेशन और फर्द और भी कुछ है
तो एन्यूमरेशन में वो भी हम पढ़ेंगे
कंप्लीट एन्यूमरेशन में तो ये इतने चीजें
कवर होने के बाद आपका एन्यूमरेशन सेक्शन
कंप्लीट होगा देन आपको देन उसके बाद
एक्चुअल फील्ड में आप उतरो ग इतने सारी
चीजें करने के बाद ओके तो एवरीवन क्लियर
नेक्स्ट दो मिनट है अगर आपको कोई भी डाउट
है मुझसे पूछ सकते हो उसके बाद हम सेशन को
एंड करेंगे और डे आफ्टर टुमारो फिर से
हमें सेम सेशन में मिलेंगे और इतने
स्टूडेंट्स आना और अभी क्या है कि डोंट
स्किप एक भी क्लास स्किप मत कीजिए क् हर
एक इंफॉर्मेशन वैल्युएबल है इतनी डिटेल
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं
होगी कोई डाउट है किसी
का तो मुझसे पूछ सकता
है नेक्स्ट टू
मिनट एनी वन हैव एनी डाउट्स
उके नोट्स अपडेट हो
जाएंगे यह तो है के आपके हाथ में है कि
हाउ कैन वी मोटिवेट आवर सेल्फ इन दिस
जर्नी बिकॉज अभी चीजें तो मैं आपको सिखा
ही रहा हूं प्रैक्टिस करना आपका काम है और
जो इसके ऊपर जो रिसर्च करनी है आज तो
मैंने आपको रिसर्च करने के लिए इतने
टॉपिक्स बताए इतने टॉपिक्स बताए हैं आप
अगले 10 दिन भी रिसर्च करोगे और अगले 10
दिन भी उसके बारे में पढ़ोगे तब भी आप तब
भी जाके आप क्या कर सकते हो बेटर कंटेंट
बेटर आर्टिकल लिख सकते हो तभी जाकर आप
लिंक दिन में पोस्ट कर सकते हो कुछ भी मत
पोस्ट कर देना तो एक बेटर आर्टिकल जो आपको
हमेशा हेल्प देगा हमेशा हेल्पफुल रहेगा
आपकी इस जर्नी में आप इसको एक चीट चट का
भी जो जितनी भी कमांड होती है ए मैप की जो
भी स्क्रिप्ट यूज होती है जो भी फ्लैग का
यूज होता है तो ये सब आपको मतलब उंगलियों
पे हो जाने चाहिए मैं आपको पढ़ाते पढ़ाते
मेरी उंगलियों पे हो गया है क्योंकि यह है
यह है यह है इसका मतलब यह मुझे अभी ओके
मैं पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कर रहा हूं तो मुझे
अभी क्या मतलब है टीसीपी से सीन स्कैन से
या टीसीपी स्कैन का यूज करना है या मुझे
इसका यूज करना है तो हम इसको रूट रूट यूजर
बनना पड़ेगा ये तो आपके कॉमन हैब चुअल हो
जाना
चाहिए रखें फिर क्लास को एंड करते हैं फिर
ठीक अगर किसी कोई भी डाउट नहीं तो सेशन को
एंड ओके गुड फियर
अखिलेश कुछ सीखने को मिला
ओके सेशन को एंड करते हैं फिर बाय बाय टेक
केयर एंड नेक्स्ट सेशन मिलते हैं फिर बाय
बाय टेक केयर सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन
नेक्स्ट सेशन जो आपका रहेगा वह रहेगा डे
आफ्टर टुमारो जिसका प्रैक्टिकल जो वर्जन
बच गया
है ओके बाय बाय गुड नाइट टेक केयर एंड सी
यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन h